it's kind of a weird news day we got uh
reports that
saudi arabia may be secretly negotiating
with china to sell oil in the yuan which
could threaten the us's position as the
reserve currency and then make all of
your prices skyrocket saudi arabia
denies it but they're also inviting xi
jinping down to the country
they've also rejected a phone call from
joe biden which was so embarrassing that
even trevor noah made fun of him and
somewhat kind of defended trump saying
it would never happen to him it's kind
of a weird weird time man and everything
just keeps getting weirder we got a
bunch of other stories just just around
this and um you know idaho has just uh
what is it idaho did that abortion been
at six weeks i think right beautiful
yeah i'm not exactly sure if it was six
weeks we were just talking about this
story it's that close that's huge and
with the potential ruling from the
supreme court over roe v wade or the
impact on roe v wade it's going to be
substantial then we've got uh um
buzzfeed is suing because a bunch of the
employees got left holding worthless
stock because you know buzzfeed is
worthless but of course uh oh i'm sorry
there's another big story too uh project
veritas has just published
footage of the fbi raid on their
journalists homes which we're definitely
gonna get to as well
but uh some people you know when we
initially put this video up the title
was different then it was changed and it
was changed and i'm just like you know
man
i'm i'm gonna level with everybody we
changed the title i was i was out of
frustration and i was like okay the bomb
squad's here there i'm done i'm done
with it because we've been dealing with
that and it's kind of cut into our
normal prep time and uh that's right the
bomb squad is here they're currently
still here and um
they're dealing with issues and i kind
of just thought you know we were like we
shouldn't talk about what's going on
with with these you know swattings and
things like that and then i was like if
this was any other outlet or personality
we'd be all over this story we'd be
talking about the threats the violence
the escalation but because it's us we
just like oh no don't bring it up and
i'm kind of like i don't know maybe we
shouldn't so there's kind of a halfway
point where there's some things we just
can't talk about for
law enforcement reasons but we'll we'll
get into a little bit about that i guess
just to give everyone update on what's
happening to the best of our abilities
you know and explain why i decided
ultimately that we probably should talk
about it
so we'll do that joining us today to
talk about this and much more is luke
rosiak do you want to introduce yourself
sure it's great to be with you guys big
fan of the show i'm a daily wire
investigative journalist i cover schools
lately done a bunch of stuff but lately
i've been doing schools i'm the guy that
broke the loudoun county a lot of the
stories that made loudoun county go kind
of national including the cover-up of
the rape
and i'm just out with a whole new book
on schools called race to the bottom so
i've kind of become somehow the school's
guy yeah yeah i mean this story is huge
i think your story actually changed who
the governor is basically
yeah it's been crazy to see and to
create crazy to see all the parents
waking up i mean
we're we're in a period of really i
think historical upheaval in this
country politically where the dynamics
are changing you got the asians coming
out because they're all worked up about
the school's issues you've got
traditional democrats who would have
voted for bill clinton and now they're
like if this is the democratic party now
that wants to like get rid of math
magnet schools they're voting for yunkan
so you know change is afoot so as we'll
mention thanks for coming in we also got
seamus yeah great to be here also thank
you for the work you're doing i'm really
excited to dig into some of this it's
very important and
i am the creator of freedom tunes and so
i'm obviously going to be promoting that
also promoting prayer in light of
current events please pray for us if
you're a praying person hi everyone ian
crossland over over here uh hit me up on
ian crossland.net if you'd like but
let's get this show rolling and then i
am also here it's been a very exciting
evening i'm sure we'll get into what was
going on on our front porch and uh talk
about what's happening in the news
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to support our work and let all the
naysayers know they cannot stop us yes
as a member you're keeping all of our
journalists employed we actually had a
meeting with a cool dude we're not going
to say exactly what's going on but
talking about expansion and a lot of
help to make the company bigger and
better and more powerful but uh
membership is how it's all basically
funded so if you like the work we do at
the website if you like the members only
segments of this show sign up watch
those segments and support our
journalists we have a member's only show
coming up it'll be published around 11
or so p.m so you don't want to miss it
but don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends let me let's
just just talk about the security issue
real quick as kind of the introduction
so
i don't want to give specific details on
why or what's happening
um
as many of you know i think out of all
of the shows in politics we may be the
most swatted of 2022 yeah six six so far
it's crossed state lines the latest
incident that we're dealing with now uh
the bomb squad
uh surprise to me i go outside and i see
a bunch of vehicles pulling up and then
i see a guy get out he's got to share
this bomb squad on it and now i was like
oh the bombsquad's at my house huh and
uh
you know i can't say exactly what
happened but it's effectively a swatting
not the exact same thing
and uh
man i got to be careful about some of
the details there's a lot to say but
maybe i can't actually say it there's
concerns obviously when we talk about
these security issues pertaining to
swattings or otherwise that if we
highlight it it encourages it and we've
had police tell us that before and i'm
like you're right you know and so some
of these instances we've we've not
really talked about that much the other
concern is that
making sure people are aware of what's
going on is is important for the safety
and security in in a similar sense i
would hate to have something happen
that would be unbelievable confusing or
just over i don't know how to
exactly explain it my concern was
you know if something keeps happening
and we ignore it and people don't know
what's happening and then something
serious happens it'll take everyone by
surprise maybe we should be like hey put
a put attack in this something's
happening we're having security issues
people should know what's happening but
most importantly you know before the
show we're trying to figure out how to
title what was going on and talk about
what's going on i was just like i said
this a moment ago if this was any other
outlet if it was crowder if it was the
daily wire if it was the new york times
we would be talking about it for a half
an hour we'd be we'd be exploring who
did it and we can't even get a lot of
those core details so
other than that i just you know
when we were trying to figure out what
our lead story was
usually we're up in the studio we're
sitting here we're talking this time
we're out in front with a bunch of cops
and i'm assuming feds and stuff like
that and so we didn't have the same kind
of ease of prep work and understanding
we normally get to do and so we're
trying to figure out you know do we do
we lead with this story oh no no we we
put one up those like joe biden sucks
and we were like he does and we want to
talk about those things but then it was
just like it's an opinion statement and
it's just like well we have the story
from from james o'keefe but he didn't
actually upload the video yet and i'm
like oh did i just accidentally you know
break his story before him so i'm like
we got to change it i'm like you know
the bomb squad's here yeah yeah i can't
deal with this i find it's like the
balance of as a
weird internet celebrity whatever you
call this weird new genre of like you're
a creator your personality is your
character
you got to balance out your own mental
health with the journalistic integrity
of documenting your life so that people
know in the future like what you went
through and so they know what to expect
if they're going to try and reproduce
what you're doing
sometimes talking about the bad things
that happen to you is bad for your
mental health and you have to just
let it fly let it go
as we talk about you know the conflict
in this country and the culture warden
stuff i'm also kind of concerned that we
would omit relevant news in this space
because it's happening to us right i
don't know if you guys what your
thoughts are on that because because
there's the self-interest thing where
we've had the cop be like
don't tell anyone this happened because
it'll make it worse and i'm like yeah
but if there's a new york times
journalist outside filming all of this
they'd post that online in two seconds
and tell everybody what was happening
regardless of our security or otherwise
and it would be a major topic of
conversation about the escalation and
what's happening with these political
conversations with censorship with
violence and things like that
yeah no it's a tough call i
can't tell you one way or the other i
think that you have total control over
the information here at least with
respect to whether it gets out i mean we
don't really have anyone else from the
new york times filming this obviously
things can get out either way just
because of people telling their family
members about what's happening things
along those lines but
yeah i'm not sure man it is a tough call
i think it makes sense on some level it
makes sense to talk about it just
because people should know the danger
that is present in discussing these
issues publicly or how psychotic people
have become and how psychotic people
have become as well and i think they
should also know that having any kind of
public political platform does come at a
cost and i'm not saying that so that
people can be
you know more careful and and more
afraid to speak out about their values
when they need to it's actually the
exact opposite to embolden them and have
them say these maniacs cannot intimidate
us
into silence yeah especially when
there's lots of people doing it together
when people start speaking out together
it's like you can't whack all the moles
at once you just give up at that point
the moles on the garden look you've done
a bunch of stories that have really
riled a lot of people up i'm curious if
you've dealt with similar stuff or if
you have thoughts on you know i think
there's a lot of keyboard warriors
online that want to intimidate and
there's a lot of people and this is not
what you're doing what happened to you
is serious it's happened a number of
times a lot of journalists want to play
a victim you know someone i got a death
threat and it's like some guy like sent
you a dm on twitter that's like you know
like i wish you were dead like all right
that's not a credible threat right um
but when you look at what's happening
with january 6th there's been like all
these long magazine articles like the
journalists are having to go to therapy
and i think what you've dealt with is
objectively probably more serious than
those journalists that were there for
essentially a riot so uh that that's a
good point and it's a big component of
like what how i'm feeling when they're
saying like don't tell people this is
happening and i'm like
we just said that story from project
veritas i don't know if you guys saw it
where that the journalist was like you
are not traumatized by january 6. you
know did you see this video where he's
basically saying like you are out there
having fun you are not worried
and they the
the uh the democrat narrative on january
6 is like the violent insurrection the
journalists narrative on everything they
do is like every day i wake up and
someone sends me mean words yeah and
then it's like
we actually have
we were swatted six times now we've had
an incident where the bomb squad's been
deployed and you know i don't want to i
can't go into details but there there is
a reason for why they're deployed it
wasn't uh um it wasn't the same as a
swatting like something actually
happened we have to be careful about
discussing the full details but uh
it caught it cause whatever happened was
serious enough where they actually
called reinforcements so like
i'm actually worried we're gonna hear
you know the house shake or something
like that like there may actually be
something about to happen
there's no way well i'm asking people
pray i mean if you pray the rosary pray
the rosary but just prayer in general be
very very appreciative there's not
really an instruction manual for this
kind of career path so i think this is
just par for the course probably it's
just a matter of having a precaution set
up like perimeters set up where things
get
looked at and inspected on their way in
so that we don't come to a point where
security security is insane well and all
we're getting crazy with it i'll also
say this i i definitely understand the
argument that it could be dangerous to
speak out about this to some extent
because then you incentivize copycat
criminals or you embolden the person
who's doing it in the first place but as
you've mentioned we are living in an era
of crocodile tears and i think it's
important for people to see people who
actually are put in a situation of
danger not falling apart and losing it
because they want to score cheap
political points with their hysteria
well i'm just you know
shouldn't uh the new york times
have talked about any one of these major
instances where we got swatted like live
on air what's up for them
right right and so what i kind of see
here is you'll hear the narrative from
the corporate journalists about how
they're so oppressed
but they obviously have disdain for us
they don't care about us you know that
what happens to us is not news to these
big corporate entities but whatever
happened to them is yeah i mean you're a
journalist who's literally being
attacked as are the people around you as
is james o'keefe as is james o'keefe and
so you know it's it's funny how
if you are outside the establishment
it's clear there's there's two there's
two uh different worlds here those who
are actually resisting those who are
actually standing up for the individual
or for rights uh and those who are
shills for corporations those who are
shills for themselves are grifting you
know do you think there are elite people
that are elite that are actually trying
to help the individuals and not shilling
for corporations or so you can be elite
and not be a shell bro i mean like we're
a big company we make a lot of money you
know what i mean like i was asking
sheamus
he was like elite are the people that
will never get in trouble for what they
did
that's a horrible way of
spaying the truth to me shane thanks um
but can those people that never get in
trouble be good people too that's what
i'm wondering like or are they just kind
of ousted like elon musk he's definitely
wealthy enough to be in that group but
is he accepted in that group because
he's not a sociopath at least doesn't
seem to be that's an interesting
question i mean they say absolute power
can corrupt absolutely so it's difficult
to find people in that kind of a
position who have the integrity to
behave decently but i'm sure there are
some
that's promising
yeah there's look you can look at donald
trump and especially with what's been
going on uh earlier today i'm looking at
all the news and i'm like thinking like
man what is the lead story you got
you've got russia sanctioning hillary
clinton and joe biden and hunter biden
i'm like that's that's interesting but
does it really matter is it you know
then you've got some crazed you know
some angry i should say chris but some
angry tv hosts in russia saying someone
should tell the us you give us back our
money or you get the tactical or
strategic your choice which is in
reference to nuclear strike against us
and then i'm like but he's just some guy
in tv i mean it doesn't really there's
some guys waving his arms and then i'm
just like um and then i i saw someone
tweeted about trevor noah uh ian miles
chong tweeted about trevor no because uh
he was saying it makes no sense to doing
the vax mandates in new york now because
kyrie irving couldn't play but he could
go and hug the players as a fan it's the
craziest thing ever and then i just
thought to myself like man joe biden
really is like the worst president we've
ever had isn't he and then i'm like well
woodrow wilson yeah he was bad too
though yeah we were talking about this
before the show and it's a complicated
question because even though i really
didn't like obama or clinton i
definitely didn't think w was the best
if someone asked me who's the worst
president i probably would have pointed
to woodrow wilson but there is something
about having a person in the oval office
who literally cannot speak that makes me
reconsider that position or want to
reconsider that position biden could be
the worst president we've ever had and i
don't say that for sure
being a bad president can take different
ways you could be a like a private socio
like a psychopath that's like uses the
law to bend to his will that's a
horrible president but then you get the
demented human that can't function
properly that doesn't speak that's a bad
a word i mean in my opinion that's more
dangerous i'd rather have a an
authoritarian psychopath that at least
is gonna help the country function uh
mechanically this guy is like
embarrassing us
when he speaks
that's a good point let me let me let me
ask you guys this question and then
we'll bring up this story uh so first we
have a story i'll just show this real
quick what we're gonna get into trevor
noah ripping joe biden's from a few days
ago
but um i think it's fascinating to see
that even people like bill maher and
trevor noah who would never give donald
trump a single good day not even after
he took out the leader of isis they
still they called him an austere scholar
they would not give trump the credit
you know
something seems to be changing but right
now we're dealing with a president in
joe biden that i believe could be
presiding over the collapse of u.s
dominance around the world the end of
u.s imperialism whatever you want to
call it and you know ian you mentioned
in just just previously that you'd
rather have an authoritarian psychopath
who's making the country work than
someone like biden but no let's let's
explore that i mean
is it is it better to have someone who
cracks the whip but fixes the problem or
someone who sits back as everything
bursts into flames and falls apart who
is also also who also happens to be an
authoritarian psychopath on top of that
well that is obvious
my patience is running thin either
extremism in either of those directions
is a bad thing i would think because you
don't want someone so authoritarian
psycho like hitler that would just like
mobilize and take in conquerors but you
don't want someone that's so checked out
like biden that he can't say words
properly or even give a state of the
union he couldn't do it he just gave a
campaign speech he couldn't give a state
of the union because he may not even
know what the state of the union is he
was like slurring his words the whole
time it was actually he got all very sad
work done on his facelift i mean did you
see the bingo thing we did luke no we uh
we had like a bingo cards
for the state of the union and one of
them was like if joe biden uses a fake
word
but he kept slurring so much and
stuttering that would like that counts
did that count as a fake word or not you
know saying like to
trade to traders were like meanwhile
when trump did that like he was tweeting
and he there was some obvious
auto-complete and they made fun of him
for like three years
right
yeah that was great but the problem is
really i mean biden can't speak first of
all trump had an odd manner of speaking
it wouldn't be hard to find someone that
could just speak in normal english and
they managed to not do that but if biden
totally keels over and we've got kamala
harris she can't speak either i mean
just being able to speak english is like
the lowest possible qualification yeah
she's got the nervous we talked about
this before the show a little bit like
the nervousness where like if i let
myself be who i really am i'm gonna say
something wrong i'm gonna put and that's
the thing is we don't know who any of
these people are biden is clearly not in
charge of the country but who is and
it's the same thing with commonwealth
who is behind the scenes here's my
favorite quote from kamala
it is time for us to do what we have
been doing and that time is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
it sounds like the arthur theme song the
the title of this article from
thecut.com is come again come on oh
right on
this just can't talk either it was like
that article was like trump did
something in a bathtub no one knows
about maybe but we don't have any other
oh no an elevator yeah an elevator you
ever seen that article from the
huffington post no uh some trump did
something somewhere
what he did we don't know what what you
know who was there we're not sure but
it's the holy grail and i'm like wait
what
but even this article right trevor noah
ripping donald trump or i'm sorry
ripping joe biden and saying donald
trump would have been better is really
significant because to these people on
the left trump is literally hitler and
even if he doesn't necessarily feel that
way his audience sure does so for him to
be willing to say let me give points to
the person who my side has literally
been referring to as hitler for years
and years because the current president
is doing so poorly doesn't really say
good things for joe biden so let me let
me let me quick just jump back to this
yahoo story right trevor noah rips biden
over saudi uae phone snub report would
have never happened to donald trump you
uh uh so
this is like finally now i'm surprised
to hear this from trevor noah
i want to show you why this is so
surprising we have this tweet from
huffington post my favorite a tape might
exist of trump doing something in an
elevator though exactly where that
somewhere is and what that something
might be no one in media can say that's
because no one in media seems to have
seen the tape or is even confident it
exists
this is
trevor as an investigative journalist
how do you feel about that headline i
think we might see a next pulitzer prize
winner yes we can yeah yeah how much
what about they did win one i'm sure
look at that image of trump's face too
this is amazing
maxwell's stretching is that someone
chasing him in trump tower and they're
like trump trump and then he wouldn't
look at him but they took the picture
anyway yeah so so
it's crazy that
in their hysteria they created an idea
of something that didn't exist they
didn't define what that idea was
this article really does embody we hate
trump for no reason
now you have these liberal pundits
coming out and being like
maybe trump you know wasn't so bad
so what really really just man i'm so my
i got a headache and everything and i'm
just like
all these people that were screaming we
have to stop donald trump he's an
egomaniac he's a fascist and now we are
dealing with quite possibly the worst
administration we've ever seen in the
history of this country maybe you can
argue woodrow wilson was worse for a lot
of reasons maybe buchanan pre-civil war
but uh right now
the u.s
there's there's a lot of things
happening in terms of soaring gas prices
inflation manipulation lies
escalating war you know i saw a leftist
post on facebook they said if
they were basically saying why didn't we
enact a no-fly zone before the war even
started when it was ukrainian airspace
and ukraine had the right to agree to
the united states and say we could do it
that would have forced russia to break
our you know red line and i thought it
was an interesting point because if joe
biden knew all this was happening if
ukraine and everybody knew russia was
going to do this then we could have gone
in and secured it before the war even
started and it would have been incumbent
upon russia to be the ones to aggress
against nato not the other way around
you look at afghanistan and bagram air
force base all of it is basically just
failures of entail intelligence failures
to act or do anything that would prevent
war now i suppose you can argue they
must really really want war
but when i kind of look at everything
the bind administration has done i'm
thinking you know what maybe they're
just maybe maybe incompetent as an
understatement yeah well i mean drawing
a line in the sand there and and stating
a no-fly zone prior to russia invading
regardless of whether you think that
would be a good idea is an idea which
would require actual decision-making and
leadership and he's not capable of that
he's the worst
the worst military commander i've ever
seen in the united states you know the
downside of his age is obviously his
senility but the upside is he should be
more moored to the democratic party
before it took this illiberal turn which
is very very dangerous where they're
just kind of you know they've turned
against the first amendment they've
turned against neutrality under the law
the younger generation has but bill
maher
what he's saying is no surprise because
he's a guy of a certain age he remembers
the democratic party of 20 years ago
which is a reasonable party um biden
knows full well he is he is a part of
that party and yet he doesn't have the
spine to stand up against the uh the
young woke mop yeah when bill bill
crystal i don't know the guy personally
but he was a big part of like
orchestrating over the iraq war with the
bush administration he's basically
people what people have told me is that
all those neocons now are just in the
democratic party they just
there's the war the war party basically
and whatever you want to slap d or r on
it doesn't matter because they're all
administrative states well and it's
interesting because people like chain
the cheneys i mean they're part of the
war party and now they're essentially
democrats or at least list genie is yeah
that's wild
yeah well that i mean they see that
that's a party full of people who are
much more likely to comply with whatever
you tell them yeah
well joe biden's behavior really makes
me think that he's certainly not the one
pulling the strings which generally
makes me wonder what's actually going on
because it's obviously not kamala
because i've said this before on twitter
and i got roasted for it but i think
that she knows she's out of place she
knows she's out of her depth listening
to her explanation of the invasion of
ukraine she's like russia is a big
country in ukraine's a little country
and russia went into ukraine that's bad
i was like are you serious but she was
talking to a black radio station which
is like it's one of the most racist
things i've ever seen yeah i couldn't
make up my mind i was like either she's
being super racist or she just says no
ideas
yeah but is it is it easier i mean is it
simpler to just say no one has the
strings
you know yeah my view of gary has been
that joe biden is in charge but everyone
knows he's asleep
even trevor noah in that segment was
like biden's in bed by 4 p.m yeah so
it's hard for him to schedule phone
calls with saudi arabia who's eight
hours ahead i mean it's a good joke but
so is it like the chief of staff like
rob klein or whatever is that the guy
that's running the country i know i
think i think they're all sitting at the
table
and joe biden's sitting there and they
all sit down and they're like okay joe
you know what's going on and he's like
turn it on a shot at a pressure and then
like kamala looks at rob and they just
like
okay
uh so
what's the agenda and he's like oh come
on man yeah the president and then they
just get up and leave and they're like
well we have no agenda we have no plans
the president fell asleep let's go let's
go bowling yeah exactly if the president
gives no orders they can do whatever
they want basically until they're told
to stop or there's nothing there's no
there's nothing there's no nucleus yeah
it is or at the very least it's a
damaged nucleus yeah joe biden you know
super chat someone said uh kofi david he
says my kofi was my favorite word until
i witnessed the magic of true nanasha
pressure that's
that's true i mean think about
trump had to accidentally tweet a word
and everyone went nuts biden actually
took the the energy to say
a much much longer and more absurd word
more than once too yeah
yeah i mean he's not just an empty suit
he's worse than that yeah he's really
worse than that and there is something
very sad about the fact that this
country has become so divided and hyper
partisan because of the encroaching far
leftism that has hijacked the minds of
the democratic party many of the
american people especially as the right
wing has started moving to the left and
it's gotten to the point where you don't
even really get to consider whether
someone's going to be a good leader when
you elect them you're just looking at
their policies
and so the democrats were not concerned
with whether joe biden would be the
right person to leave this country they
just said well he's not trump and they
picked him on that basis there's a story
right now the white house called in a
bunch of tick-tockers yeah and
the big guns i feel bad for the tick
tockers there's like some 18 year old
woman who's got like 10 million
followers yeah and i watched her video
and she was just like gas is high
because vladimir putin and i'm like
she's literally just quoting gensaki
yeah and i feel so bad for her because
she's clearly well intentioned like i'm
gonna help my followers she you know i
see these tick tockers and these are
people who do like entertainment content
if they're willing to take time out of
their day to actually address serious
political issues that's actually a
really good thing but when they're being
manipulated by the white house to push
lies to prop up a guy who's gutting the
system that they live under and making
their lives worse i'm like that that's
just they're willingly taking part in
propaganda no but they don't know better
right so look we can say the path the
hell is paid with good intentions but i
think the issue is the you're you're on
tick tock you film videos of you doing
makeup and you know hang out with your
dog and you get 10 million followers or
whatever and then along comes who you
think is the authority who's got your
best who's got your back because you
don't know better and they're like
here's what's happening and you go i
better tell my followers about this so i
can help them i can respect the good
intentions
i don't fault an 18 year old kid from be
for being lied to i blame the white
house for lying to them and manipulating
all of these young people what i think
is weird though is i assume these are
attempts to reach quote the youth and
these are young tick talkers and they're
just kind of echoing like what the man
tells you and i i thought you know
growing up i thought part of being a
young person was being rebellious and uh
they're just kind of just regurgitating
whatever the government tells them to i
wonder if young people still have that
spirit of uh you know rebellion yeah i
mean
some of them i mean maybe the reality is
most young people weren't rebellious
just some of them were the the people
who went on to become you know leaders
and and challenging the system
innovating and disrupting they were
rebels but i think most people probably
aren't they're probably just conformist
i wasn't very rebellious i had to learn
to rebel i had to kind of teach myself
how when i learned how corrupted the
system had become like in 2007 i was
like well i really have to i can't just
live under this boot even though i'm
really wealthy do you guys remember when
casey neistat
endorsed hillary clinton oh
so yeah 2016 he's uh one of the biggest
youtubers he's got five and a half
million subs at the time now it's way
bigger and i think he's like
semi-retired i'm not sure he doesn't
really produce as much as you sue and he
made a video where it's like his channel
is about travel and adventure and then
all of a sudden he's talking about
hillary clinton and he said it's because
this election wasn't about politics it
was about one egomaniac and his quest
for power or something like that
and that hillary clinton was the only
person who could be trump and i was like
casey who told you that huh because
that's politics and you were lied to
and it's provable hillary clinton could
not beat trump she lost to him and it
was so bad they didn't try to bring her
back for round two she was in fact the
one person who could lose to trump
because i'm pretty sure they could have
brought in almost anybody and probably
beaten trump but hillary was absolutely
despised so they go to these influencers
people like casey who don't know
anything about politics and i don't i
don't mean that in any way
disrespectfully he's not a political guy
they tell him here's the thing and he
goes okay i'm gonna go say that and he
was completely and utterly wrong he's
come out later saying he was a mistake
and he shouldn't have done it and he's
right trump ended up being
actually a really good president
bad in some ways for sure nobody's
perfect
but setting a timeline for getting out
of afghanistan trying to get out of
syria best numbers of our lives in term
of terms of
economics in 2016 and 2019 a lot of good
things under trump he was jammed up by
the the neocons and the neoliberal
establishment they had scandal after
scandal holding him back tying his hands
and he still did some good things far
from perfect but pretty good way better
than biden i don't know what
what uh what would have happened with
hillary but those ideas were just wrong
then we get the same lies in 2020 when
these social media influencers came out
don't give a special shout out to people
like contra points
who said you have to vote for joe biden
do you regret saying that so now what
we're getting from the propaganda
machine is aren't you glad trump isn't
president why
even bill maher is saying it's a good
question why didn't putin invade ukraine
under trump
so no i think all of these people who
came out were like guys look i'm a
leftist and i don't like the
establishment but you have to vote for
joe biden it's like there's no logic
there at all because if you really
wanted the system to collapse donald
trump was the ball in the china shop if
you really wanted something good you
want a repeat of trump's economic plan
that helped everybody with a good
economy there was literally no reason to
vote for a war-mongering corrupt despot
like joe biden and they did and now gas
prices record highs inflation for four
decade highs every single month
wholesale consumer prices up 10
escalation of war our southern border in
shambles
everything's worse more covet deaths in
2021 than 2020 even with the vaccine i
mean no student debt relief
now the dude's totally turned his back
on black lives matter all of these
people who advocated for this sold out
their followers burned it to the ground
and now joe biden is just sitting back
yelling tuning out a shop out of
pressure as everything falls apart
it's amazing how easily manipulated we
all are and i think that's you know the
the lesson from the last couple years
with coronavirus and masks and all the
left has been doing is calling someone
racist and then you have to do whatever
they tell you to do and then if not
you're it's like it's not a clever
scheme it's like super
obvious uh or you know you've got to do
this because trump is bad and that's all
they have going for them it's not it's
not clever at all it's not subtle
but people keep falling for it so what
would you say the solutions are or what
direction do you believe we have to head
in as a country to fix this
i mean i think we have to the democratic
party really has to reject the illiberal
left i mean these ideas of treating
people differently based on race
rejecting objectivity in some ways like
these are insane ideas um with some of
the school stuff where they're talking
about you know getting into they got rid
of the some of the math magnet school
the top math school in the country
because there weren't enough blacks
getting in so they said tests are not
real like you can't indulge these ideas
that's a conspiracy theorist there's a
conspiracy theory they call people on
the right conspiracy theorists all the
time so i think the only people that can
save this party joe this country joe
biden was
well situated to do it because he's a
democrat that is not grounded in the far
left fringe and uh unfortunately we've
learned he's not the guy to do it let's
talk about how joe biden may be
presiding over the end of american
global dominance from the wall street
journal saudi arabia considers accepting
yuan instead of dollars for chinese oil
sales
talks between riyadh and beijing have
accelerated as the saudi saudi
unhappiness grows with washington
now there's two big points to make your
first some people are screaming it's
fake news don't believe it and there's
some reporting coming out saying it's
not true it's not true it's not going to
happen
however what we do know as i mentioned
in the previous segment even trevor noah
criticized joe biden because saudi
arabia refused to take his call we also
know they invited xi jinping to the
country at the same time we're hearing
reports that they're considering trading
oil in yuan what this will do is it's
going to strengthen
chinese currency and their government
and their economy substantially
it's going to send signals to everybody
that if if saudi arabia does this
because they trade exclusively in u.s
dollars
that it's good for you to have you on
because you can buy oil with it now
that is
the the first you know chipping away of
us global dominance in terms of the
petrodollar the reserve currency and
what what americans need to understand
is that a large portion of the wealth we
have wealth we have comes from the fact
that we are the progenitors of reserve
currency around the world if that ends
we have very little to offer everybody
else yeah exactly i mean think about how
much the value of our dollar is boosted
by the fact that everybody has to
purchase u.s dollars if they want to buy
oil from saudi arabia i think it's not
just saudi arabia too yeah exactly
yeah i think of saudi as uh like the
nozzle on the hose like the the garden
nozzle that you squeeze to squirt it and
if and we are the hose you know we're
producing the the fluid that's coming
through this hose but if saudi wants to
twist shut we have no more way to get
that oil out to the world if they don't
want to sell us dollars that's like the
tip of the species so does this also
make inflation much worse if we printed
all this money and now all these foreign
governments are no longer possessing it
yup yeah exactly if they start dumping
it then we're going to have dollar bills
in the streets being shoveled into the
gutter and i just don't understand how
people could be too shocked that we
present printed what 80 percent of the
dollars in existence over the past 20
years there's something along those
lines in circulation yeah i'm sorry in
circulation i mean
of course we're just going to be inching
towards losing our status as world
reserve currency why would anyone be
willing to depend on our currency well
this is why the white house is so
desperate they called in the tick
tockers to lie to young people they're
going to also it's not our currency the
u.s dollar is federal reserve currency
it's a private budget but we don't have
the congress doesn't control it anymore
what bothers me the most about what the
white house did with these tick tockers
it's basically just like spitting on
these kids
like kids who are finally asking why is
my gas seven bucks in la that's one
thing that this young woman said she was
like we want to know why gas around the
corner is seven dollars a gallon it's
because of putin and i'm like it's not
it's literally not because of like ask
yourself why california has seven dollar
a gallon and you go to arizona or
colorado it's four dollars but that's
the oldest mind control game in the book
is you need a common enemy when things
are tough you need a distraction and you
get everyone worked up and now we're in
war mode and we've got an enemy so we're
all going to come together
dude after 9 11 it was the craziest mass
formation psychosis people wanted to
blood they wanted to be in the middle
east and then they're like and iraq and
they're like yeah whatever man i'm
hungry feed me look at what they're
doing with ukraine now
there's a comic mocking leftists and i'm
seeing leftists post it so i'm actually
like good where it's like
russia says you know uh there's weapons
of mass destruction and they're like oh
you know okay we're okay with that now
like the the united states invaded iraq
because of weapons of mass destruction
boone's got women's mass destruction we
can invade russia no of course not
because russia is actually a threat to
us the issue is you have all these
leftists who pretended to be anti-war
who said war is bad and now that ukraine
is is all in the press and on the media
they're all waving the flag saying we
got to do something and they also
impeached trump for suggesting
essentially that biden had some oddly
close relationship with ukraine and sure
enough it's seeming like he does i think
it's undisputed that he his son was on
the board of charisma well that is
undisputed yeah it's indisputable for
sure biden is interwoven in that
ukrainian right but he was trying to
claim like oh it's no big deal that's
just my son i don't know like he's
clearly like obsessed with ukraine and
has been for years and that was kind of
at the heart of you know the impeachment
is trump was kind of right like why why
are you into ukraine so much dude like
it really doesn't have anything to do
with us i i'm just asking do you think
it was that he just wants the landmass
to move oil or is there something
more i mean this is just a wild i don't
know if you have the answer to this but
what do you think it is why biden's been
obsessed with ukraine for so long
oh i have no clue other than you know i
i mean we know that obviously his son
has a lot of money ties there but i have
no no clue oh boy it's like the bread
basket of yours just walking over grab
their water but come on ian either
russia we talk about cover this all the
time either russia or europe wants that
ukrainian bread basket they want to know
their country
about 20
of natural gas i believe goes through
ukraine from the company gazprom which
russia controls
this allows russia to control prices and
make them very very high so what we end
up seeing in in europe is energy prices
are pretty high what happened when
france tried putting a small petrol tax
on the on the people for climate change
reasons so they claimed climate change
people rioted for a year and a half
so the us and and western interests
destabilize
the middle east which syria
somehow we start seeing western
resources like mike's plumbing end up in
the hands of jihadis
you know oh yeah
us support for rebels the u.s allies
supporting isis
and it was destabilizing assad very
convenient for us because we wanted to
get rid of him so we could build our
pipeline to offset the gas prop gas
monopoly then you get
you know
trump comes in
trump flattens isis russia is like okay
good my ally is is secure trump was
doing things that was ending war it's a
good thing isis is bad got rid of it
this de-escalated tensions between
russia and the west that's a good thing
joe biden gets in and what happens
immediately you start seeing that you
start seeing activity in syria again one
of the first things we saw under biden
and everyone talked about it was we're
hearing reports that u.s troops were now
moving back into syria of course that's
going to make uh putin very angry
because
syria is an ally and and uh russia has a
military base a naval base in tartus so
now u.s troops going back in was once
again aggressing upon russia and its
interests then you go to ukraine the
west starts pushing again
and then russia says okay we're done
we're not doing this i'm looking at a
gas prom first time i've really looked a
gas prom yeah it's not like they control
literally all of the gas right it's 120
billion in sales in 2019 they said it
was rated the largest publicly listed
natural gas company in the world
and the largest company in russia by
revenue that's right the largest russian
company so biden was trying to get the
oil away from gas problem and start
taking compete with it with a different
company is that charisma
uh it may have been barisma barismo was
an energy company just so happens that i
think there was a cia director on the
board there was a hunter biden on the
board getting paid 83 000. that's some
deep states right no these are just
corrupt people man they're getting like
i mean bureaucrat administrative
bureaucrats on the board of ukrainian
gas company
it's it's it's it's as corrupt as they
come
but uh the simple picture is the the
united
were interested in destroying the
nations of syria and ukraine to save
money on gas
and iraq let's not let's work they're
sucking that oil out of that country as
we speak libya too
iraq uh iraq a little bit that was um it
is seemingly iraq and afghanistan was
like bolton's wet dream of invading iran
so afghanistan and iraq really allowed
the united states to position a bunch of
military bases on the west and east of
iran and then you ended up with bolton
under the trump administration saying by
this time next year we will be
celebrating in tehran and it was just
like man this guy's nuts because iran is
not
not like afghanistan it is a mountainous
well-defended country with a lot of
people and i think they have really
really great surface-to-air missile
capabilities or like anti-air
capabilities iran or iran iran yeah yeah
i imagine the russians are they allied
with with the russians i don't think i
don't think so dude i don't know if
you're it's a foreign policy i imagine
they've been loaded with russian
weaponry or chinese weapons probably
point but this is what's starting to
happen these are the two blocks so um
yeah
the scary thing is when you when you
consider this
and then you consider what
it's it's almost like the administration
in power right now is a zombie version
of what it was during obama like
it's trying to walk in the direction but
it's just failing miserably and now with
saudi arabia making these moves they're
not answering his phone because they
don't respect him because why would i
talk to joe biden that guy's not doing
anything
i think the world looks at the united
states and they say they're fractured
within their president it can't speak
straight he'll do nothing to stop us
and there was a
russian tv presenter who said
that we can russia can do anything
including biological or nuclear attacks
and the united states will do nothing to
stop us that's what they said on tv
and that's i believe a legitimate
viewpoint
our adversaries now have well and you
have to look at china i mean china
potentially unleashed a biological
weapon in some capacity and we've done
nothing yeah i was sort of talking about
that on the show the other day the fact
that we argued it was an act of war when
non-government russian actors purchased
46 000 worth of facebook ads but china
releases a virus which is according to
surprise
what what's that release virus was
released
even if it's accidental if a country
accidentally does something which kills
were being told over 800 000 people it's
hard not to consider that an act of war
yeah at least
but within our borders specifically
blocking congressional hearings i mean
we don't know definitively the answer to
these questions in part because they
refuse to ask the question i think
because eco-health alliance was involved
that it's it's multinational at this
point who do you go after you know what
is it is for forex trading is something
people do right foreign exchange buying
one oh yeah i think so how much you know
i'll tell you this
i'm i'm confident the chinese currency
at this point i'm not confident u.s
dollars i'm not confident in fiat at all
i think this is fiat the owner is also
fiat
trillions of them i'm not going to buy
any chinese currency but bitcoin
for sure can't print bitcoin you can
only create what's already there mine it
yeah yeah yeah i i i'm every day i i
hear more and more news where i'm like
how long has the dollar got left yeah no
joke man 18 years it's it's it's it's
like it's the weakest currency in the
world strong you know what i mean if you
look at um you know
for instance ukraine i mean they're just
currency is brutally when you see those
countries that have trillion dollar
bills right yeah
but
how long you know how long until the
yuan takes over as the reserve currency
maybe not overnight but it looks like we
may be moving that direction
people look i think when it comes to
these currencies you'll take a look at
the strength of the government that
because the currency is backed by the
strength of the government
if the u.s can't maintain the the force
against other countries to use its
currency for oil they'll stop
and the u.s can't back up their their
words with guns anymore it's not working
russia is proving that china is proving
it
china has a strong and stable
authoritarian government and kovitt
really shined a light a lot of other
countries are looking at this and
they're like well you know when push
comes to shove china will weld weld your
door shut and execute you
over the united states joe biden will
fall asleep
joe biden was given the keys to the you
know he was given the vaccine he was
given uh all these policies and more
deaths and more cases in his first year
than under trump in his last yeah and i
think part of it is americans are so
especially the people that want to talk
about colonization and think of
themselves as globalist they're actually
so sheltered that they can't situate
international affairs they're they're
they live within america that's really
all they understand and they hate people
like trump more than they hate our
foreign enemies and so i think a lot of
what they're doing is purely designed to
play on american politics when really
the world is much bigger than that so i
wonder especially when you see these
npcs with their ukrainian flags and
their bios and things like that uh this
is really just residual russiagate
hysteria where you know russia bought
fifty thousand dollars of facebook ads
oh my god but then the mueller report
everything falls apart and they've got
nothing and now this is like their last
stand of like see we told you russia is
bad
it's just so crazy to me that um
there exist people uh for whatever
reason
that live in that reality
where it's like smilet story was a hoax
they believed it covenant kids hoax they
believed it michael brown hands up don't
shoot was a hoax they believed it russia
gave they believed it ukraine gate they
believed it i'm like i don't understand
at what point does your brain just break
from all the lies that are proven to be
lies or
is there something in intrinsic to their
minds where it's like the lie is better
it's always better to just fall in line
how many of these people actually know
they're being lied to but are too scared
to say anything so they just keep going
along with it how many people are just
so dumb they can't and you never see any
reckoning like you never see just even
regular people that are posting on
facebook and things like that this
mullet happens and they're all up in
arms you never see them follow up i was
wrong or i've learned a lesson i mean i
think we need an apology at some point
because if we're not learning from these
things
uh you know
they're obviously going to keep keep
happening if there was just some
accountability a tiny amount like you
mentioned just people having to
apologize when they got something
completely wrong if we tried to foster a
culture where people held their friends
accountable for getting outraged over
things that turned out not to be true
far fewer people would but as it stands
there are literally zero social
consequences for spreading lies that
will promote your political agenda
because when it turns out you either
were lying or someone else was lying to
you and you irresponsibly believed it
despite the fact that they have
constantly lied to you in the past and
you were willing to listen to them again
there is literally nothing anyone says
to you to even remotely bring you any
level of shame for the fact that you
have made the system work based on
complete misinformation and that you're
probably going to continue to spread it
in the future
i'm visualizing like humans walking a
tightrope and i'm down on the bottom
watching them all fall off the tightrope
and like i can try and be like hey
here's how you walk a tightrope but it's
so assuming time consuming and
impossible to teach these people that
don't know how to walk it so i'm just
focused on building a better net because
they're going to keep falling these
stupid people these moronic hive minds
and they always have this circular logic
where it's like okay it was fake but the
fact that i could have believed it could
have been real only shows that the
underlying problem is truer than we ever
knew that's so true
that what a crazy statement but ian in
your analogy it's not that you're
watching them on the tightrope you're on
the tightrope and they're bouncing
around and struggling and it's making
you wobble that's for sure and you're
saying guys please
here's how you walk on a tightrope and
they tell you to shut up and then one
guy pulls out a knife it starts cutting
away at the rope and you're like okay we
got a problem the upside of that is all
the wobbling has made me become a better
tightrope walker but it's still annoying
when they wobble the tightrope yes ian
all of the chaos has made me better at
survival yes truth be told thank you for
the assistance looking forward to that
tightrope snapping and then i hold on
and swing like tarzan off to safety like
as you're talking about these people
just buying lies over and over again i'm
like getting frustrated and then i start
to get angry and like i can't help those
people anymore and i try that's a really
important point i mean there's an
emotional cost to all this like it's
just not fun to argue with your friends
who are saying this stuff that you don't
agree with politically you see the
people that put the effort into really
kind of being congenial and saying well
where'd you get that let me question
this assumption it's easier just to
ignore them because it's just grueling
it's just uh you're on a treadmill and
it's frustrating and uh i think people
just give up and that's where you start
to see this country separating because
it's just not fun i mean who wants to do
it let me let me pull up this story that
this is from daily mail gop rep madison
cawthorne claimed he carried weapons in
his wheelchair on january 6 to arm those
around him in unearthed clip of a phone
call now hold on there a minute what
the first thing i want to say such a lot
the left is using this
uh to to insinuate that madison
cawthorne was trying to arm rioters
that's not true madison catherine was
talking about arming members of congress
and their staff
two years opens against the rioters
here's the best part though
unearthed clip so saith daily mail huh
what does that mean
this was on a public broadcast it was on
the charlie charlie kirk's podcast i
believe this wasn't unearthed anybody
who watches that show and it's a very
popular show knows this was said they're
saying on earth because they don't view
you as a human being and citizen of this
country you don't matter your
conversations don't matter they
unearthed it i love that analogy
christopher columbus did he discover
america no
well first of all he landed in the
bahamas but if you want to talk about
discovering the continent there were
already people here from a european
historical perspective that's that's it
right that's how i view this these
people are like look what we've
discovered and it's like bro i saw that
episode like that was a long time ago is
this news to you
i didn't actually see the episode that's
the point though they say this
cawthron was interviewed by phone on
conservative activist charlie kirk's
radio show on january 6 seemingly while
rioters were actively storming the
capital the freshman lawmaker said
everyone around me is armed but didn't
say where he also claimed rep lauren
bobert was carrying a weapon that day
the colorado republicans previously told
fox news just days after the
insurrection that she had not been armed
that day but said others were well then
maybe madison catherine was incorrect
because a direct source contradicts it
neither caught thorn nor bobert have
responded to a request for comment
so if um an insurrection is happening
against sitting members of congress in
the government and one of them is armed
and says quick the writers are coming
take this weapon shouldn't the democrats
be happy about that shouldn't they be
like wow he was actually threatening
lethal force against violent
insurrectionists he's stopping the
insurrection he was fighting back that's
right that's right madison catherine
tried to save this country from the
insurrection that's the headline right
insurrection where basically nobody
brought any weapons right that
insurrection
well some people brought weapons not to
the capital but you know they had
weapons in their cars and stuff like
that but the craziest thing about this
is there was a reddit post i saw
where they're they're they're pushing
this idea
that kawthor and bobert were arming or
mostly corn was arming rioters like they
were giving they're claiming that a man
in a wheelchair was about to commit like
a lethal terrorist attack i mean it's
he's in a wheelchair i mean who's going
to be afraid of him i don't know this is
another story where you can see they lie
they manipulate the truth to make it
seem like it's odd because the daily
mail is conservative but it's also
english so we're kind of coming this is
an odd story for that reason and it's
it's literally it's a complete
misrepresentation of what happened
it is a completely misrepresentation of
what happened on earth and also yeah
carried his weapons in wheelchair to arm
those around him are you leaving a
little bit of important context out of
that one
yeah a little bit i'm just gonna say too
that i can't believe how deeply
entrenched their ideology is because for
them to look at something like someone
actually bringing a weapon where it
might need to be used and scream and
point and freak out that's silly to me
like he was possibly
potentially defending some of these
people but they have to control the
narrative so that it looks like he was
trying to arm the rioters when in fact
we know that a huge majority of the
people there did not even have arms at
all which
flatly contradicts their ongoing
narrative that they were there to cause
trouble and due violence to the people
who were at work there is this is this
show uh this is the charlie kirk show is
was this is is it the same as his
podcast do you guys know or no i think
so not sure this was uh charlie kirk's
investigative reporting of having a
public conversation yes i'm sorry yeah
[Laughter]
but no i mean think about that when so
to these people in in in the media
because look i know it's i know it's
daily mail is is is conservative and and
they do often they're kind of you know
they can go either way it's a big
company um
the the reason they say that is because
the the the reddit threads and the
comments about it were like newly
discovered clip
these people in in establishment and
corporate press
they think you you watching a show it
doesn't exist
they have to discover it and then say it
was discovered
but it's kind of like bro if if
if there's millions of people already in
america and then you show up i tell you
but you didn't discover it there's
people here well it it makes me wonder
luke as someone who does genuine
investigative journalism and asks to
interview people and comb through
information and find original sources
when you see that people can watch a
podcast clip a moment from that podcast
and then call it journalism how does
that make you feel
uh you know i think there's a couple
issues here the first is kind of
ascribing malice when you know
incompetence is an easier explanation
there's a lot of journalists now that
aren't really even journalists they're
lazy low-paid 22 year olds who don't
know anything about anything and they
just literally like look at reddit and
write a little blog post um you know but
the other thing is when i was doing the
loud and county story and i revealed
this cover-up of a rape the other media
didn't cover it and by doing that they
relegated it to this conservative media
story and so i think that sometimes it
works to their advantage a story becomes
stigmatized just because they didn't
cover it and then they you know it's
it's circular reasoning they they cause
it to be a conservative media story and
then they say well we don't need to go
into the conservative ghetto and read
things because if it's a real story
it'll come from us conservative ghetto
it's a good way to put it yeah we need
parallel economies
you know it's there was a point where i
said i'm worried about it with the
censorship and everything that it was
going to force people into two separate
economies now it's time
the the the anti-establishment it's not
even just conservative but the
anti-establishment post-liberal
libertarian conservative whatever group
need they need their own infrastructure
we need our own payment processors which
there there are some we need to
basically tell these people we just
don't care anymore you know it's not
that we don't care it's that it's
pointless trying to talk to people who
don't view you as a part of civilization
or society when they when they when they
actually act as though you are like some
kind of
you know
peasant or uh subterranean humanoid
creature who's not on par with them and
their nobility what's the point in
having a conversation with that person
they consider your outlets fake news
if i'm gonna write a story
and then they say it's unearthed or they
call it you know conservative news says
that's just like i don't care who
they're talking to those people are are
you know
they're not paying attention they're not
interested in paying attention
so so we got to find people who are
actively looking for answers and want to
improve themselves you know you can lead
a horse to water but you can't make them
drink as they say so i don't know
maybe we do want to try and wake a lot
of these people up but for the most part
i look at this and i'm just like
they they view you as an unhuman you
can't make them drink you can make them
thirsty but that's arguably thursday run
them around a lot salt then when you
take them in the water they're more
likely but that's with a human that's a
little unethical to use using like a
horse you know so i don't know if making
people thirsty well
you can reason with a person i mean
attempt to dude reason it people are
seeking logic and reason they need it
it's part of the balance of the spirit
and i think it's missing so maybe you
can bring reason to people that might
help i mean truth be told you can
definitely make a horse drink i kind of
understand the saying it's like you can
bring the horse to water and then you
can splash a bucket in its face
you can jam a you know a hose in its
face or something and spray it and it'll
it'll get mad but you know
it depends on how many people you have
you could you could tie the thing down
and pour water and it's horse abuse
well like if you've got a horse that's
dehydrated yeah it needs to be probably
you interve uh what do you call it
subcutaneous fluids yeah i'm a little
injection under the skin
horse iv drip yeah
you know when i when i see stories like
this
and it's just another day another same
story
i just wonder you know what's what's the
next step in the escalation and the
polarization and the splitting because
now they're actually trying to insinuate
that a sitting member of congress is
arming rioters for an insurrection
this is just completely consistent with
their narrative and this is something
they've refused to let go of which is
really interesting to me to watch
because even in the midst of ukraine and
all their posturing and politically
correct virtue signaling about how much
they dislike russia they still have time
to point out that oh january 6 was still
truly terrible never mind that ukraine
is actually being shelled by russians
this is still the worst thing that's
ever happened on american soil just a
bunch of old people who wandered into
the capital building
november is going to be lit oh yeah it's
already been lit this year
yeah that's crazy for us yeah
well one thing i want to mention here
about the median media bias i'm sure you
guys can probably relate to this on some
level unless your evolution occurred
more quickly than mine but even just a
few years ago i understood and viewed
the media as being left wing and having
that bias but i still thought
i can see what they're saying and every
once in a while they might get something
right but at this point my perspective
is that they are always lying all the
time and i can literally trust nothing
that they say and to sort of segue into
your investigative reporting when you
look at the loudoun county case with
them referring to a father who is angry
over his daughter literally being raped
in a cover-up in the media reporting on
this is if he was some kind of maniac
and the face of
parental abuse of teachers
yeah and i mean what i did with that
story was so simple that everyone saw
the story on cnn the video every news
outlet uh of this guy being arrested
this kind of overweight white male
plumber that got beat up by the cops and
handcuffed at a school board meeting and
they all thought they knew why they
didn't need to ask him why he was mad
because they all thought they knew he
was a bigot he probably hates gays he
probably hates blacks who knows but we
know um and so all i did is call him up
and say look
your video is being played around the
globe we all saw that you were mad why
were you mad and he told me that his
daughter was raped three three weeks
prior by a boy wearing a skirt and the
superintendent had just lied and said it
never happened so uh
it is uh you know baffling and they're
they're it's not as if the investigative
resources aren't there i mean they
literally were
went out of their way to obtain video of
this guy and put him on tv but no one
thought to call him yeah i mean that's
that's really a horrific part of this
scandal is you literally called the guy
and that's how you got this information
underneath the absolute minimum that
these journalists should have been doing
let me let me read for you a quote from
george orwell sheamus
you know what really frustrates me about
the orwell quote stuff though is
whenever you do it they pull up his
fictional writing and i'm like no no
tell me about the man in his
recollections of history and
observations so this is one of his
greater quotes
he said
early in life i had noticed that no
event is ever correctly reported in a
newspaper but in spain for the first
time i saw newspaper reports which did
not bear any relation to the facts not
even the relationship which is implied
in an ordinary lie i saw great battles
reported where there had been no
fighting and complete silence where
hundreds of men had been killed i saw
troops who had fought bravely denounced
as cowards and traitors and others who
had never seen a shot fired hailed as as
the heroes of imaginary victories and i
saw newspapers in london retailing these
lies and eager intellectuals building
emotional superstructures over events
that had never happened i saw in fact
history being written not in terms of
what happened but what ought to have
happened according to various party
lines how little things change amazing
how little things change shame it says
spot on because
i look at this and i'm like that's
exactly what we're seeing now
it's amazing has it ever really changed
has it always been that way i think it's
always been like i think so but what's
really fantastic is the fact that at
least for the time being the average
person does have the ability to look
into things on their own so alternative
alternative media didn't really exist at
that time in the way that it does today
we are able to broadcast our messages to
literal thousands if not millions of
people
well and i came across a meme the other
day was talking about if the news is
fake imagine what history is like and
i'm like that's really interesting
because we all know history is written
by the victors but who knows what their
take on it was
who knows which part of the victors is
actually recording what happened let's
uh let's let's segue over to this next
story which uh victory may be a a um
contributing factor in an upcoming civil
war here in these united states
from timcats.com idaho passes bill
banning abortions after six weeks idaho
senate bill 1309 is modeled for similar
texas legislation passed last year
the bill now goes to governor bradley to
be signed into law little has supported
similar abortion bans but has not yet
offered public comment on this bill the
abortion bill does include exceptions
for circumstances such as rape incest
and medical emergencies the current
abortion laws in idaho authorize
abortions until the fetus is viable
outside the womb typically around 24
weeks if the governor signs the bill the
new idaho abortion ban could take effect
as early as april so we're seeing
similar laws uh they mention uh over at
tim kest uh mississippi there's there's
texas and they say at least 12 states
have introduced bills model after the
texas abortion ban the texas law senate
bill 8 empowers private citizens to sue
anyone who helps facilitate an abortion
after the legal limit
this is a big story because six weeks i
think is in terms of what we've seen
across the country the shortest amount
of time so far i believe right because
like 11 weeks was mississippi and they
got sued over that now at six weeks
a lot of people even people on the left
believe that roe v wade will be
overturned come what june so this is
just another
another you know uh shot across the bow
maybe it's not even a right way to put i
mean there's another law
leftists abortion activists are going to
go after this absolutely but it may be
meaningless if come june
they issue a issue a ruling overturning
roe v wade
well and of course they will not be able
to stand the fact that unborn children
are not being murdered in your state
even if that continues to be legal in
their state
well i think there's sort of a defensive
mechanism here as far as i think one of
the big issues in our country is when
people move from california or new york
to texas
because because of texas success it
actually leads to failure um and so by
doing something like this it's actually
not even about abortion what it's saying
is those people in in seattle and
washington state and oregon right over
the the state line i believe of idaho
who are moving into idaho it's saying
stay out and it's necessary to do that
because otherwise idaho will become uh
portland in however many decades very
interesting
i hear what you're saying but think
about the implication there
do you believe that there are um
women
who are
scared that if they go to idaho they
won't be able to get abortions like
it's just kind of a crazy thought to me
that there's a woman who's like but what
if i get pregnant and i can't terminate
the pregnancy in this state you know
what i mean
so you're suggesting if a woman wanted
an abortion and she was in an eye she
was an idaho resident she would just
cross the state line to get it well not
necessarily what i mean is like the
implication is effectively if this is
true that this bill is a warning to
these people the only reason they'd be
scared is because they plan on having an
abortion no because they're obsessed
with virtue signaling i mean look at all
the boycotts they do of florida and
texas for all kinds of bills that really
won't affect almost anyone it's just a
symbolic gesture that this isn't you're
not going to fit in here it's amazing
how they lie too like we i can't get
over the florida uh parental rights bill
which i keep lying about constantly well
and with this i'm not sure why they
decided to do it i want to just ascribe
the best possible motivation to them and
say they're really trying to save unborn
children and really god bless them for
doing this but i do think it could have
this very interesting side effect you
bring up if you're left-wing people
being willing to move to these states
but that said on the other hand you're
mentioning virtue signaling here and an
important part of that concept is it's
completely hollow and meaningless so i
think there could be reason to believe
that these left wingers still might end
up moving to these places just because
all they know how to do is engage in
hollow symbolic virtue signaling and
their actions never map onto this yeah
so the things they say they want so we
you know i i deal with this when we
we've been looking at property in west
virginia more so than past year but now
that we have the new property
hasn't really come up but one of the
issues is
we hear a lot from locals that there
will be maybe a pig farm or a shooting
range and then these dc people who are
trying to escape the cities over covet
and other problems that they create move
out here when they go to buy the
property they're told now you have to
sign these documents saying you
acknowledge there's a shooting range and
a pig farm nearby and it's going to
stink and be loud and they go oh yeah of
course
but what happens then when 10 more
people move in all around the pig farm
and shooting range now there's more of
them than you and they say okay we did
agree to that but now we're gonna have a
vote oh look at that we've all voted to
get rid of your property and now you're
gone yep so that's one of the things we
see so i'm not entirely convinced the
leftists will be like oh no we better
stay out they're gonna be they're gonna
move in and go wait i can't do what and
then eventually enough move in and they
say vote get rid of it you know what i
mean yeah i get what you're saying
though about it it's sort of a prelude
to a civil war or some sort of national
separation is the 50 states uh
just in increasingly uh
states going far left and far right and
so there's a differentiation within the
country even if nominally we're still
one um because people are very mobile
now especially after coronavirus a lot
of people working from home i think
we're going to see people
self-segregating politically absolutely
yeah yeah so so that was the point i was
bringing up initially is that um
i think abortion could be a great moral
cause
for the left or the right which could be
you know on par with slavery of course
the left will
probably scream at me for saying
something like that like what or maybe
they'll agree no they'll agree because
they say it is literal slavery for a
woman to not be able to murder her
unborn child right i've heard that it's
like the moral issue may be on par with
that denying a woman her right they
could say
what did george carlin call it being a
brood mayor for the state
if that's if that's the left's
perspective on you know bearing a child
when they decide not to or they don't
want to then they probably would agree
it's a great moral cause on par with
slavery but if that's the case and
you've got there's no there's literally
no middle ground there's yours there's
zero middle ground it's just there's no
so how do you how do you resolve
something like that
if they overturn roe v wade i think
you're going to see a bunch of states to
start banning it and then i wonder you
know will you see leftists setting up
makeshift underground the underground
abortion clinic railroad or things like
that for sure
you think so oh yeah abortion since the
dawn of humanity has been part of us
species i can't imagine stop it ever
stopping
i was so i'm sure that some people will
still attempt to have abortions but i
believe that it will be greatly
decreasing in number in the places where
it's illegal but i think what tim's
asking is not necessarily will there be
people who break this law but are left
winger is going to try to set up an
entire underground infrastructure to
continue abortion to get a girl out of
the state without people knowing yeah
something i would imagine yeah because
if you think about if you think about it
if someone lives in a state that allows
it and they don't want to get one they
don't do anything they just say i'm not
going to get one
uh but so another reason why i do
genuinely believe that
abortion bans work
is because i mean this was a while ago
and i can't remember the exact state but
planned parenthood tweeted something out
i i don't think it was the um the texas
law because that was too recent but they
basically tweeted a frowny face about
how in certain areas where abortion was
more difficult to access the birth rate
had increased i have to find this
it's actually ridiculous um i'll see if
i'll see if i can pull this up but i
mean people also the a the law is a
teacher and b if abortion bans didn't
decrease the prevalence of abortion the
left wouldn't be upset by them
that's a good point and one that's very
relevant because i think that they're
afraid of actually changing the thinking
about abortion and about things like
parenthood and i think that very much
goes back to feminism and telling women
that they have to get rid of this
unwanted child if it unfortunately
happens to them we don't know how this
happens but you know children happen and
you have to get rid of them somehow and
they just fall flat because they're like
well if you wanted to stay at home and
be a mother you would just have a kid
and you couldn't abort them and then you
could be a worker and i think that also
gets back to communism but that's very
strong and i think there's a sort of a
pattern emerging of the democrats
becoming the party that hates children
with closing down schools for two years
because of their deference to the
teachers union which is a vicious and
ruthless thing to do i mean children
killed themselves because of that
children are going to be illiterate
irreparable harm was done um you see the
things like uh you know covering up the
rape and loud and you see things like in
florida where they want to groom your
kids at the age of uh
you know kindergarten uh into being you
know transsexual or whatever um this is
almost
another thing is the er and this is
important coming back to the migratory
patterns that we're seeing with
coronavirus
democrats love urbanizing areas if they
can build dense buildings
that is how their real way of taking
over an area you want to have more if
you have more than an acre you're going
to be conservative if you have less than
an acre you're probably going to be
liberal
wasn't that a big thing that uh you know
they wanted to uh urbanize the suburbs
absolutely they want to get rid of and
joe biden this was part of his platform
to ban single-family zoning and so they
think we should all live in cities and
take trains or buses everywhere and that
is an anti-trial policy too because as
anyone who has children knows you're not
going to go to the store and lug home
four gallons of milk and you know costco
size you know whatever all the stuff
that we all do as parents it's
impossible to do
uh in this urban lifestyle and democrats
are obsessed they want you to live in a
high rise they don't want you to have
land um it is uh really anti there's a
number of ways that the democrats are
anti-family beyond abortion i think when
you get out of cities and actually
experience
having land and space you'd never want
to go back dude the cities were another
reality before the internet in the 90s
late 90s to early 2000s it was the only
way to go to get involved with anything
bigger than farm town usa so i went to
new york city 2001. you want to be an
actor now you don't need any of that
online is the city that's where everyone
gets together power goes out
your immediate community is key if the
power went out then maybe we'd start to
form i think maybe cities was like a
stepping stone of our evolution towards
but that's if the power stays on if the
electricity goes out
then it's hard to keep waiting for star
link man
we're getting we're getting uh uh solar
upgrades we're you know we're waiting on
um starlink
so once we have starlink it's like you
got
i hear it's not that good you know you
know initial test runs were you know 100
megabits or something but now i'm
hearing that once everyone starts using
it it drops down to maybe like 10 or so
but it's it's like um lower latency
which means you can game and do stuff
this means people could be working out
of montana dude you know so it really
allows people to kind of spread out and
i think one of the biggest problems is
population density in cities makes
people go insane no freedom do you work
on a boat with starlink you could live
on a boat in the ocean i wonder if that
explains some of the irrational behavior
the high strung nature of some of these
uh
you know hyper online uh leftist
journalists and things like that just
the mental stress of living in a city
dude i mean when i when i worked at uh
fusion my apartment in brooklyn
was two grand per month and it was they
called it a two bedroom because the
living room in the kitchen were one room
and then the living room was a bedroom
so it was a two bedroom it was a one
bedroom but that's how they do it i know
a bunch of journalists who lived in
railroad apartments you ever see a
railroad apartment in new york city a
railroad apart railroad apartment is one
long room with doors every third of the
way so you have a bedroom with a door in
the front in the back and your roommates
walk through your room to get to their
room oh wow it is amazing it is a
bizarre dynamic where they're all
lecturing or looking down on everyone in
the middle of the country and the people
in the middle of the country are just
laughing at them like dude i'm sitting
on my deck looking at mountains looking
at uh you know i had some urbanists
lecturing me and i was like i'm looking
out my window and i i see a fox taking a
nap in my apple orchard which was true i
had 40 40 fruit trees and and a fox was
taking a nap and their only report was
you're lying um
so they just they can't comprehend that
people actually do live this way and it
doesn't necessarily require more money
or anything it's just
our way of living is better than theirs
let me let me let me tell you about um
what's a good deterrent for keeping
urban city city urban liberal types out
we have the story from timcast.com ohio
becomes 23rd state to pass
constitutional permit less concealed
carry uh gun law
ohio joins a number of other states to
uphold the second amendment right of
private citizens bravo ohio welcome to
the club west virginia of course uh
constitutional carry i love it because
that means that uh if you're armed in
west virginia you can pop over to ohio
no big deal because it's all
constitutional care you don't got to
worry about that's the way it should be
but man and the state laws are so great
because the problem is if you try to if
the if the country were to separate in
some sort of civil war there's no way to
draw that line because the democrats
live in cities there are no democrats
there are no blue states there's only
blue cities right and so you'd have to
create some crazy border line that just
somehow encapsulates all the cities
they'd be cut off in seconds but they
can't create their own uh democratic
enclaves within states when you talk
about these issues like guns and
abortion those this still apply in the
cities no matter what they do when i
talk to my friends about uh
you know concealed carry when i talk to
my my more liberal gun controlling
people i know
uh
it's funny because they they can't
fathom why it would be a good thing and
it's like worrying to them and i love
tweeting it just triggering the left i'm
like more guns buy guns and they're like
oh and they get all angry and um
i don't want to say the dude's name but
one of those activists like i tweeted
about everyone should buy a gun or
something like that or it was something
silly trolley where i was like more guns
you know guns for everyone and then he
got like all offended and scared and i'm
just you know i answer my friends
they're like why should so what why is a
good thing and i was like that
regular people have the same rights as
the politicians
like do you think politicians should
have special privileges that regular
people don't do you think powerful
corporations should have special
privileges people don't do you think
billionaires should have special
privileges people don't well guess what
the billionaires walk around with guns
the billionaires got armed security the
millionaires got armed security the
politicians got guns the politicians got
armed security politicians are allowed
to carry in dc you're not so when they
pass constitutional carry i see it as a
great normalizer you want you want to
this is the united states we're all
equals it's a representative government
the you could nancy pelosi is no more
politically powerful on legally than you
or i now on paper and the way reality
and society works of course she's got
political power and clout and all that
stuff the point is if if you know i grew
up in chicago
politicians are armed
armed security you screw you in one of
the worst gun crime you know cities one
of the worst gun crime states no oscar
that everybody has a right to keep and
bear arms let's equalize it if you get
to so do i
i love it it's pretty awesome because if
the fall the roman republic if the
citizens have been armed caesar may not
have been able to overthrow that
republic probably wouldn't have been
able to
so it's obvious that we live in a deeply
divided country we just have different
opinions and they're probably not
reconcilable um the idea of a national
divorce is probably pretty obviously a
pretty radical and
uh untenable probably proposition but
one of the things we can do now
at the local level is incorporate new
towns so if you live in a large county
like where i live in fairfax virginia
especially basically all of the south i
think it grew out of the plantation
system the counties are the primary
governments now it's different in places
like new jersey where you already have
these little towns but a lot of people
live in these sprawling county regions
and one thing you can do is start
incorporating new towns and smaller
local governments that better reflect
your needs so if you want to live in a
communist utopia go for it and if you
want to live right next door in the in
the in the right-leaning town go for it
but um states republican states can
empower basically to create a new city
uh that can have its own police force
its own laws its own prosecutor its own
everything tax rate um you usually need
to be granted a charter from the state
so what republican legislatures need to
do is say look if any
geographical boundary and you can create
you're on your own you can just say look
these 100 square blocks or whatever draw
your own boundary on a map you put it on
a ballot you get a referendum if 51
percent of people want to form a new
town boom you have a new town you run it
the way you want
so we got free damastan out in west
virginia i think you need 100 people
residents to form a town
is that is that what it is maybe so then
uh we'll we'll once we reach that number
of people we'll be like how would you
like to be a city and then you know
we'll incorporate for damastan and then
we'll have a town and then we'll start
creating laws like you can't censor
people and of course a town of 100
people will still have very little
weight against the might of say twitter
or whatever but it'll be really
interesting to see how our city's police
force deals with filing you know legal
paperwork with the state they're in
violation of city law how they'll
respond to it and of course schools is
one of the big ones here uh that's
because schools will be fun you know
because we're gonna like everyone will
basically agree on what schools are
supposed to be what they should be pod
schooling
that kind of well no i mean like if we
have a school district and we
incorporate a town we're going to be
like crt get out like i don't care if
you teach kids about the like so i we we
talked with one of our guests about this
because he was like you want you want to
ban people learning about critical race
theory and i'm like no no we want to ban
the indoctrination of kids under the the
ideology of critical race theory if you
came to me and said i would like my
child to read a book about critical race
theory and the bible and marx and um
you know which one was uh adam smith
the whatever if they want to read out of
smith i'd be like by all means let's
teach the children about the ideology of
adam smith and karl marx let's teach
them about the ideology of these
critical race theorists
not indoctrinate them well let's teach
them basic math first because we haven't
managed to even do that yet yeah no no
absolutely what i mean
it's funny how we're having a
conversation about complex ideological
ideas when these kids in these in these
in fourth grade should be learning
division and that's the issue with all
this stuff in the schools it's designed
to distract from the fact that we've got
11 kids proficient in american history
24 in math 36 in reading those are
deeply embarrassing so we bring critical
race theory in and says tests aren't
real objectivity isn't a real thing
wanting the right answer is a function
of whiteness it's really just a
distraction it's all about the the whole
um
debate over critical race theory has
really been a bit of a um like a
distraction that's the whole
it's all it comes down to the academics
when you're doing your book race to the
bottom does that would you just
constantly uncover it like what were you
uncovering when it came to the
distraction of cr yeah i mean that's
what i thought it was firstly you know
like the shutdown was insane you know so
many families were devastated like how
are you supposed to work and watch your
kids at the same time does anyone even
care and then of course crt but when i'm
looking into it like our kids are our
country is so screwed because our kids
do not know math they don't know how to
read and write uh what is going to
happen and we're not talking about way
out in the distant future um those
statistics i just mentioned are for 12th
graders so they're going to be voting
next year they're going to be employed
next year um this is the most imminent
national social security threat to our
country math is interesting it's a
language i think of it as like if you if
you miss a week of homework and you
don't follow like what the term means
then when they use the term next week
you don't know what they're talking
about and you have to learn the language
as you go yeah so like if you missed
three or four days of math it's hard to
catch up without learning because they
teach you terms they're giving you
language a language class basically um
whereas history you can just pop in and
start learning and then if you miss a
spot you can kind of fill in the gases
math is a tough one this is one of the
problems i have with school man to be
completely honest that it's like
everyone must learn at the exact same
pace or else yes or too slow are left
behind and those are too quick but sit
there bored and confused and frustrated
yeah it just doesn't work it's terrible
i raised my hand and they would just
pass over me because i kept raising my
hand over and over i'm like why isn't
anyone answering i know and these are
the people that love diversity but they
they don't
they argue that people are actually not
diverse when it comes to that we've all
got to learn the same thing at the same
time and you know
its equity is equal outcomes by race and
things like that and you get equal equal
outcomes by bringing down the top
performers so the lowest the level of
the lowest common denominator and at
this stage in america that's actually
very very low cut off the tallgrass 20
of people are proficient in 12th grade
math that are graduating these are
graduating students 24 yep
wow and it's not hard to be proficient
it's a pretty low bar
algebra i could see how algebra was
confusing if you never learned variables
geometry i mean well look there's angles
of trigonometry's little let's be real
when you live in the pod hooked up to
the metaverse and they're they're
funneling bug protein mush into your gut
straight through a tube and you live in
the realm of skyrim or elder scrolls or
whatever and you have no idea what the
real world is like you're not going to
care about any of this
yeah have you guys ever
talked about or heard about the
philanthropic foundations like the
creepy history of the ford foundation
and things like that
i think you'd be interested in that um
part of when i'm researching all this
school stuff crt
i think it really comes from those
foundations which are like you're
watching pbs and you'll hear you know
this segment brought to you by the
macarthur foundation or you go to like
the art museum and it's like oh funded
by you know the ford foundation it's
like okay these are just some nice old
rich people whatever never thought about
it before these are the most important
and secretive and creepy forces in
american politics they are
so powerful uh and they all collude so
you've got a bunch of billion dollar
organizations all working together and
so you think back to the early 1910s
you've got carnegie he's got a vertical
monopoly on steel ford obviously doing
the auto stuff it's a bunch of
monopolists and teddy roosevelt comes
along and trusts bus monopolies are a
bad thing so the families all stash
their money in these tax exempt
foundations that live in perpetuity
because they're just spending the
dividends so they live forever this this
wealth of these monopolists from 100
years ago is preserved forever and
eternity
um
the thing is okay so they're all
capitalists and now the foundations are
doing
trying to overthrow capitalism which is
ironic um but they were also racist
creeps they were capitalist racist
greeks from 100 years ago um and so you
might have heard about the kellogg
brothers i don't know i think there's
like a documentary about one
really creepy guy he's like um
uh i don't know like he
didn't he made cornflakes to stop kids
from cranking it yes yes weird stuff
about masturbation all that kind of
stuff did he promote circumcision in the
u.s or am i thinking of somebody else i
don't know but he was at the same time
all these little boys
so he thought yes
cornflakes would do something about it
weird stuff with circumcision
circumcision yeah and so their whole
thing was they were these progressive
elites that wanted to make the world a
better place and they to do that they
thought we should get rid of black
people um and so their thing was
eugenics and they you know
they lobbied they got laws passed that
you could sterilize defective people
people with mental retardation um and
essentially minorities they went over to
puerto rico and they sterilized a third
of the women over there so they you can
reproduce hispanic population into wow
american citizens um and so
by the 1940s the rockefeller foundation
had this
um seven-acre warehouse on long island
where they had boxes showing the family
trees of every american family for the
purposes of seeing who had good genes
and which had genes we should get rid of
these are creeps social engineering
creeps um you know fast forward they
continue doing similarly racist stuff
and it kind of evolves with the time it
uses different language to hide it so by
like the 1990s they're still trying to
get rid of black people but they're
doing it through abortion
and so they're they're really targeting
the black community for abortion um
anyway so that's the history of the fact
they touch on a lot of aspects of life
that i came across them through them
pushing critical race theory in the
schools and society at large but um i
know it sounds like a conspiracy theory
but it's true and if people don't
understand it because the foundations
don't they're not the forward-facing
they have fronts they give money to
these other groups that then do the
thing but it's not like they're just
donating to groups that were already
going to do that anyway what they do is
they'll say well we're looking to fund
xyz and suddenly everyone with a
non-profit says
we've got a grant proposal to do that
we're applying and so they steer the
direction of america by signaling what
they're going to put money at and then
all these activists do exactly that
that's so terrific hold on i want to ask
so you're saying they had family trees
of every american family would i miss
here that i i i don't know exactly how
comprehensive it was it was
extraordinarily comp comprehensive um
and that was the gist of it yeah uh how
can they have ancestry
you know dna 23andme or whatever they
call it impact investing what these what
these organizations have been doing and
the idea is you you put money in a
sector until someone bites and then you
basically create a sector you you and
it's going to be 21st century
devastating impact economy is on its way
this is something
allison mcdowell talks a lot about it's
definitely you see it on youtube where
people were like even just getting
people getting funded
like you make a video about x x gets
more views you might want to make
another video about x who knows where
there's views or bots or what but
somebody is giving you that impact it's
really really easy to uh throw money
behind a youtuber that you like and
allow them to keep doing it through the
shadows
you can so i i haven't used youtube ads
in some years but back in the day when i
was you know working in more in
marketing you could go on youtube find a
youtuber channel you wanted to advertise
on and advertise directly on their
channel that means you're funding them
directly without them realizing it
whether you whether it's intentional or
not maybe you're like hey i want to sell
these you know rock'em sock'em you know
robot things modeled after the young
turks so you'd put it on their channel
so that their fans would buy it that
also means that you could
buy garbage ads for no reason and just
put a thousand dollars into their
channel which they get a portion of i
think 65 or 70
so there's ways to like shadow fund
certain personalities you like so it
used to be that when it came to
journalism
they wouldn't go to a journalist and say
do as you're told or else they would
find someone who already wrote lies and
say want a job
nowadays what they do is they find
youtube channels that fit the agenda or
what they like and
you know they make sure the advertising
money is going good for them and they
don't realize that these youtube
channels that are doing well don't
realize they're actually being funded by
these organizations yeah but going back
to what you were saying about these
left-wing progressive organizations that
from the get-go were involved with the
eugenics project
it's interesting because the left likes
to play this game where anytime you
point to something that the progressive
movement did in the past they say well
that was conservative or more
conservative because it happened in the
past but we as modern progressives don't
believe in that so a progressive at that
time would not have been on that side of
the issue despite the fact that the
progressives of that era were quite
clearly on that particular side of the
issue and so the left can pick up any
horrific idea they want and when it
turns out to be a complete disaster for
everyone instead of losing any
credibility they just get to say well no
no we're forward thinking so we tried
that it didn't work but that's
completely missing the point we have to
be careful about which new ideas we're
willing to try out because they can be
absolutely disastrous if you haven't
vetted them properly and it's no mystery
that many of the most horrific tragedies
to befall humankind in the 20th century
were a result of progressive thinking
especially centralized thinking
centralizing
eugenics is massively dangerous i
understand like the idea of finding a
spouse that you want to procreate with
and that's a form of eugenics like
you're choosing your bloodline stuff so
that's like that's okay that's not too
far but when you become the authority
and you're like i want these people to
have sex with these people and these
people never to have kids that's danger
danger because who's in making those
that call you you should watch attack on
titan oh i haven't watched and i think
you might be a
yeah so uh someone kept super chatting
us jordan peterson said to watch attack
on titan and so i was like i hear good
things i'll watch it then i did if
you're interested in the idea of
eugenics if you're interested in the
idea of white privilege and critical
race theory you're critical of these
things seriously watch attack on sidon
it's crazy because uh it's an anime and
my only real understanding of the show
was like oh it's about there's this one
last city with three big walls
that keep out giant humanoid monsters
that eat people called titans and there
are people that have these like rope
systems that allow them to move around
really quickly and use swords to kill
giant monsters yeah i like anime you
know full metal alchemist was pretty
awesome i was a big fan of naruto but i
was like eh maybe i'll watch it then
when i heard the robot jordan peterson
robot tell me to watch it in the super
chat
i decided to watch it then i realized
it's actually a political thriller that
touches on the ideas of eugenics of
ancestral sin
and oppression and white privilege and
it tackles all these ideas
man it's some it's it's good stuff and
war when there's like warring countries
and then you know there's one little
girl and she's like you people are evil
your your ancestors oppressed us you
have any idea how many people you've
murdered your family deserve to die and
the other girl goes my mom didn't do any
of those things she never hurt a single
person why was she killed i'm just like
if jordan peterson did watch it he
really would tell people to watch it
because like the the white privilege
element of it and the authoritarianism i
was like man it really is a good show
plus there's giant humanoid monsters
that fight each other so you get that
yeah
but but you're it's really interesting
to hear you say it that way i mean they
essentially the the far left views
conservative as just a different word
for bad yeah so when they do bad things
they were being conservative even if
they were
explicitly doing them in the name of
progressive ideology which they were i
mean back in the 1910s there was this
sense of what do you call it no bless i
believe uh belize you know the rich
people well they wanted to use their
wealth to make the world a better place
and they had this trust in science which
became social science and so they
started doing this weird studies and so
the ford foundation wiretapped a jury
room in a major criminal trial and spot
illegally spied on americans um they
made a little spreadsheet and wrote
their little phd style paper on why
essentially we shouldn't have juries in
america because people are stupid um and
so these are a bunch of uh you know
college professor types that think they
know better than everyone um and there's
this that's the really the progressive
ideologies that we know better if we
could master plan everything the world
would be a better place and so that's
really what the eugenics came from
and there was no moment i mean i would
maybe buy it if they said there was some
moment where the foundation shifted from
conservative to liberal and we
apologized and there was this
transformation but you can go through
every decade they do the same thing
in the 60s they went into new york city
and they had this idea that we should
have segregated schools in the black
neighborhoods and they said well really
what we want is integration but the
blacks are going to have to prove that
they're capable of living
in our society first and so they use
that bizarre logic to actually take new
york city backwards and create
segregated schools and they had them do
very similar stuff to what we're doing
in the schools now where it's all like
self-directed learning no one's actually
sitting them down and actually teaching
things and so the result was predictable
like the kids did horrible they pitched
it like these these poor kids in harlem
are going to be reading james joyce
because they choose to that's not what
happened the schools failed and they
they blamed the asians somehow because
the asians had nothing to do with it but
they blamed them um and so their excuse
was look we're we're the liberal ford
foundation we wanted to integrate new
york city but we had to do the opposite
and segregate it and so
now you have critical race theory where
they're saying you know showing up on
time and working hard and um
determination doing homework those are
all not part of black culture they're
white attributes it's the exact same
thing there was no reckoning there was
no shift from conservative to liberal
they're they're
the language has changed but the result
is the exact same it's the perpetuation
of this elite um status quo and you know
the surest way to keep
you know a black underclass in place is
to make sure they don't learn uh basic
academics wow extremely well said um
extremely well said have you written
about these foundations extensively
because yeah i'd love to read more about
that that's that's part of my book race
to the bottom
it's a book about schools but it's one
of those things you start looking into
schools and you go down this rabbit hole
like everything so there's this you know
there's a million because people think
it's all about loudon and that's like
one of the weirdest things i just wrote
about loudoun because that's where i
live right i mean there's other
reporters that happened they did the
same thing we're all just being lazy
honestly and looking at our own school
district because it's easiest um the
schools the problems are are everywhere
and um
there's a
there's a nationalizing element to it
right there's 13 000 school districts
how is the same weird stuff happening in
all of them and that's where i i came
upon the foundations yeah well and the
interesting thing is is that even in red
states in places like west virginia
we're seeing school boards get taken
over by cult members and what happens is
when they run for school board for they
don't say they're democrat or republican
they lie or they just you know keep it
under wraps so we're going to teach your
kids and then as soon as they get in
it's
wokeness yeah it's interesting you were
being a little bit self-deprecating and
you said you looked at your own school
system because that was easier and
you're being lazy but i would argue that
that's exactly why we need to have a
system which encourages people looking
at their own system and what's local to
them because it is easier to solve
problems on the local level but for
whatever reason we've really
spread a way of thinking throughout our
culture that you have to be paying
attention to what's happening in every
other part of the country except for
yours yeah and i mean a couple like back
in 2019 i mean i so i spent my career as
a
you know dc journalist and i thought i'm
like at the you know in the center of it
covering congress covering all this
important stuff and i realized like
local government is actually more
important so i just straight up quit my
job and started focusing on this local
stuff because
no one was paying attention to it and
that gives i mean and honestly it's a
little silly that a lot of us in america
have sit around and
talk about our opinion of the president
and things like that um when we can't
really have much of a say like the
average joe but where the average joke
and have a say is that at the local
level and yet we just thought it was
boring we thought it was lame and no one
was doing anything it created this
vacuum that was filled by a bunch of
creeps well and it's interest well they
know
that the average joe can have an effect
at the local level which is exactly why
they try to smear people like the man
whose daughter was raped and tried to
stand up to the school board about it
and it's why they want the fbi to
classify parents who speak out against
this school board or speak up for their
children as terrorists
did that dad like make a mistake by
getting angry and screaming
who couldn't uh yeah no i think he was
actually more restrained than probably
the average person would be and you know
he didn't come forward and tell a story
even after that that's it wasn't until i
called him and he tried to have faith in
the system but the prosecutor wound up
trying to put him in jail for disorderly
conduct and this is a blm soros-funded
prosecutor who ran on a campaign of she
let like an attempted murderer out like
the week before um you know they don't
she's one of these nobel types no one
gets jailed for disorderly and so they
targeted him and he still had faith in
the system and it wasn't until the
second girl was raped because i already
knew about it by that time but he didn't
want me to come forward he was that kind
of guy he actually did he's got a bit of
a temper but he was exercising
remarkable self-restraint and when he's
when the second girl was assaulted he
said we can't trust this system anymore
i mean we've got to just take it into
our own hands did you ever come across
john dewey when you were studying the
history of the school system yeah this
guy seems pervasive this psychologist he
was right there with the rockefeller
foundation getting started i don't know
did he start a foundation or anything i
haven't really looked too deep into him
yet so i mean i think they they were all
based out of columbia university and
that's also kind of the epicenter of
critical race theory tracing it back to
critical theory james lindsay probably
told you all about that he knows way
more than me um but there's some creepy
stuff happening in columbia university
teachers college in the in the 50s and
60s
and yeah a lot a lot of bad stuff came
out of there and that's where the
foundations basically started funding
social science which is not a real
science it's just activism but they
create a lot of papers that get before
these local governments and things like
that is you can go to all these meetings
your town council or whatever but they
put this paper it looks really
complicated it's got a lot of jargon in
it and that's one of the things with the
schools too that struck me as they have
their own language that is designed to
keep people out it creates a barrier to
entry because you don't know their
acronyms and you know i learned about
all that through the course of writing
the book the acronyms are stupid i can
explain them all i know what they mean
but you know for the regular people
they're not missing out on anything the
language is artificially indeed
needlessly complex for the sole purpose
of keeping regular people out of their
own uh town government thing we should
we should have you on with uh james
lindsay yeah you know at some point talk
about all this stuff but for now we must
go to super chat so if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show if you
really like it head over to timcast.com
and become a member because you will be
supporting our journalists and we're
going to have a members only segment
coming up at 11 p.m and plus we have a
new show chicken city in about one week
we almost got 13 000 subscribers plus i
think we had the last time i counted
nine new baby chickens hatched this
morning and it's all live
happening very live on chicken city but
let's uh let's let's read some
superheroes we got roberto lara
he says amazon's amazon swattings now
bomb squads so this is what happens when
one is curious about listening to all
opinions and truths the moles always win
always win uh yes the amazon thing so um
i didn't bring it up my initial plan was
like when we go live today the first
thing i'm going to do is complain about
amazon oh they ruined my patio and then
you know the balance club yeah i was
like first world problems amazon drove
over the patio but so we got a new patio
built and uh
rain delayed it then snow delayed it and
it finally got sealed so it's like an
epoxy spray
and that means uh you can't walk on it
or drive on it and the amazon driver
decided to go off our driveway onto our
new patio and
pressed dirt tracks into the epoxy
great uh so it has to be sanded off and
resealed which is very very expensive
very expensive so i'm i was i was mildly
perturbed indeed first world problems
for sure but now we're gonna be delayed
another two days or whatever because i
gotta it was it would have been done by
uh you know tomorrow evening or the
morning now they got to come in take do
a spend a day getting rid of it and it's
gonna be another two days to wait for
the uh the seal to you know i was
thinking maybe we could build like a
platform so we can go up and sit up high
but then we are doing that okay yeah
we're building a new uh ramp wall it's
gonna have like a seven and a half foot
viewing plan oh out front yeah nice yeah
it'll be nice
all right let's see
john leonard says stay strong don't let
the people who swat you in ian keep
rolling ones and twenties i find you to
be one of the best parts of the show
even when i disagree with you i'm
extreme
uh let's see angela richter says what
mystery is sheamus praying uh so i was
praying the glorious mysteries of the
rosary what was that earlier so there
are different mysteries of the rosary
basically they are
moments from the life of christ and the
narrative of his life that you meditate
on oh
for each decade of the rosary that you
pray
all right let's let we got this one here
for uh for ian jeremy says i listened to
the show on audio the next day so i
apologize i didn't do anything day of
but this is appreciation for ian's
straight 20s yesterday look at that
we just got a super chat that looks
really big it says cop 400 000. i'm not
sure i saw that what what currency is
that can you look it up yeah i'm curious
it's you know youtube classifies it as
red but i don't know 400 000 cops from
sam colombian peso yeah
so what is 400 000 well let's see one
two three
uh so i would say ten thousand is a
dollar or five thousand is a dollar five
thousand isn't that's gonna be us next
year with the inflation that's right
we got a super chat from janna to texas
of for 13 million dollars thanks john
i'll get myself a beer 105 bucks sam
jackson says hey tim love your show was
wondering if you could help some fans
out freedom jobs business coin is
launching an amazing app tomorrow for
the cryptocurrency of the parallel
economy would be awesome to get a shout
out if you have a sec thanks so much
well if people are interested there it
was otherwise i'm not too sure what that
is but let's read some more
all right
let's see what is that cat's turbo says
where are the emails and videos pelosi
is holding in regards to j6 total bs
truth needs to be told yeah they're
withholding a bunch of information
aren't they is that what's going on not
sure no yeah luke do you know anything
about that or not i don't know well
well we'll uh we'll look into it yeah
okay let's see what we get
daryl dothro says luke please comment on
george webb investigations imran awan is
that something you're familiar with
anything about that
uh it's just this like crazy guy huh all
right then
let's see let's grab some other super
chats lauren taylor says the swatting
stuff is nuts nuts wish the best i have
some training i'd love to share please
look up resume on spin the ufo lauren
the gunsmith firearms trainer oh all
right well you know lady if you want to
check that out i will check it out
jay schartzer says biden has 1041 days
to prove he is the worst president of
all time so don't count him out come on
man that's a good point that's a good
point when i say he may be the worst he
still has a lot more time
you know he's gonna he's gonna he's
gonna
he might be the best
i mean maybe there's a possibility that
you know
he he gets struck by lightning and gets
is given access to the speed force and
then becomes
flash biden yeah or aliens start
controlling people's mind but his mind's
you can't control it because it's like
he's like no one can touch me
i'm gonna get him bro he's like frying
futurama yeah yeah you lack the delta
brainwave i'm invincible
biden's brain is so addled that they
can't find a pathway to control him so
he he's a rogue he does the bare minimum
but they can't mind control i have faith
all right
mema type says democracy republic
dictator etc are all just system to try
and keep good people uh to keep good
people in charge but you can still have
good dictators augusto pinochet rescued
chile from communism then set up
elections and stepped down he also
brutally murdered many people i heard he
threw people out of uh helicopters
i lived in chile for a while that's
pretty notorious that he did that from
communism nah man he was like a western
uh basically put into power by western
forces and did their bidding but did
westernize the country whatever
regardless of whether they were like a
bunch of obese people there regardless
of whether they like communism or hate
communism brutal authoritarians going
around murdering people seems to be the
problem you know that's the kind of
world we want to live in dude they had a
coup in chile before he became into
power um where they basically fighter
jets were flying over the capitol
building i mean you go to santiago and
they're like this is where the tanks
were pointing this is like i don't know
20 years ago or something i think it was
to get pioneer 20 years ago no no i was
to get pinochet out oh i gotta look at
my history here
joe boxer says a no-fly zone is not
possible due to the size of ukraine
compared to kosovo just the east side of
ukraine is 10 times larger than kosovo
wow interesting yeah it was 1973 when
they put pinochet in power when he
joined came to power and it was alende
salvador allende was the guy that was
president he was like i'm going to
commit suicide and then killed himself
in the building oh wow yeah mitchell
doherty has heard you mention yesterday
how words have lost meaning would
recommend everyone read george orwell's
politics and the english language very
enlightening on the subject puts the
madness in perspective smart fella
yeah
raymond g stanley junior says joe biden
says let's go brandon i agree that's
right he did that that was a good thing
he did that's amazing it was so that was
actually very frustrating for me because
i did a cartoon called thanksgiving with
joe biden where it was a bunch of
animated characters of joe biden sitting
around the dinner table is basically all
him and i used actual joe biden clips
instead of doing an impression of him
and the punch line at the end is he says
let's go brandon because the food at
thanksgiving is too expensive and i just
ruined the joke but please go watch it
anyway i was very frustrated because
that was the one thing i couldn't find
him saying so i just did an impression
of him going let's go right
but then i think a couple weeks later he
actually said let's go brandon and it
was just it was very very bittersweet
because had i had that earlier in the
video it had been so much better sorry
the great anywho says guys no one person
is pulling biting strings it's the
grandkids and kids fighting over who is
getting the family silver because they
know that grandpa is not doing so well
yeah i don't know man the big guy was
getting his ten percent that's what we
saw oh boy that's right we don't know
who the big guy is though tim you know
can't jump to conclusions maybe hunter
biden knows another unbelievably
influential player in maybe politics
wilson fisk yeah you know yeah and
spider-man no yeah he's obama obamacare
really good friends
i saw a meme and it said
uh can anyone explain where fauci's gone
they took that the hook that they pulled
people off yeah yeah
they yanked him off stage man
the wrong writer says vote in the last
election based on all the candidates
tweets and social media they don't get
my vote if they exhibit city urban
liberal type
yeah i agree with that i uh i do a few
things whenever i get uh text messages
from
democrats text me all the time
um probably because i made donations to
like andrew yang and tulsi gabbard back
in the last election and i'm like you
should probably look at who i donated to
before texting me because then they
always do these things where they're
like hello tim i hate lauren bobert will
you done it to me that's like basically
what they sent me
but typically i'll respond with how many
genders are there
and they don't respond
uh or i'll respond with you know i like
guns so it's just yes yeah so
i have never donated to any left wing
campaigns and i'll get those text
messages as well yes see the republicans
got no game dude exactly that's it
if sheamus is getting progressive i know
you know but i'm not getting it from no
honestly just stop just just i don't
care i do i think campaign texts are
just annoying
but then again the kind of person who
votes democrat
is the kind of person who would vote
based on
a spam text message so it probably does
work for them yeah
raymond g stanley jr says tim cheers to
you and the crew for maintaining your
composure and light of all the attacks
on you luke what a different story uh
luke what a diff story you have to take
home a i think maybe we're missing some
words there so i don't know if it's
coming through properly but you know
what what's stanley yeah
he says a lot of super chats maybe he's
a fixed one yeah you're right you're
great
lee uh lysandren says
lissandran donald trump for the house of
representatives then the speaker of the
house then impeach biden harris and
trump is in the driver's seat again uh
trump doesn't need to be elected to the
house to become speaker of the house my
understanding is that the uh
representatives can just elect him as a
speaker of the house it could be anybody
so if the republicans win they could do
that
anybody like they could make you the
speaker yeah oh well they should do i
don't think trump would though because
trump is running you know the knuck boys
podcast he was like they asked are you
going to run 24 20 24 he goes well
federal election laws prohibit me from
saying things unless you know but uh
many people will be very happy they'll
be very very happy maybe he was saying
his haters will be happy though we can't
jump to conclusions yeah that's true you
know but that's that's why he gets away
with you know he's going to run
i wonder if what we're going to see is
joe biden burns the country to the
ground or
joe biden almost burns into the ground
populist republicans win their primaries
republicans take over in 20 in november
do just enough because i don't really
have a lot of faith in republicans to
stop the country from completely burning
to the ground and then trump comes in
and pulls us out of a tailspin hopefully
it won't burn um i think this is an
opportunity for american democracy or
republicanism to show itself it's a
functioning as it's built to function we
have checks and balances because if you
get one bad
you know authoritat in office you want
bad president you need other branches to
keep it in check so we will find out if
it was built right here's a very
important uh super chat from joseph
suchta he says skate or die
absolutely well guess i'll die
i love that game for me
no it's true i'm actually really good at
rollerblading if you guys want to watch
that vlog aggressive in line aggressive
you got to make it sound like it's mine
it's interesting that's not in line
right now i'm number one aggressive in
life
skater boy of all time
we did a bit where we had brett who's no
it was real too don't do this to me why
are you why are you going to expose me
on air i'm never going to come on your
podcast again it was a bit where brett
was not wearing your clothes exactly did
not skate around looking like you that's
what i call a 20. the best part of that
bit was that whenever sheamus landed a
trick he yelled his own name that's like
some kind of pokemon how else are people
supposed to know that i'm doing the
trick i go sheamus
right because you're wearing a helmet
you gotta yell your oh yeah i hate you
exactly that's the only way people know
yeah
did you shame us
good time that was great
yeah we we planned to do a bunch of
other ones i was thinking it would be
hilarious if we hired like a legit like
pro motocross guy and just you know do
the same thing
convince everyone that seamus is a
really good yeah and lots of stuff like
skydiving convince people deep rolls and
stuff what people don't realize too is
like you know this guy's sitting here he
actually doesn't even do freedom tunes
no yeah wait what yeah yeah that's right
james is just an actor it would be great
to get into a stunt i'm a crisis actor
i actually animated with my left hand
i'd like to see you do a front roll flip
like in a stunt well it's going to make
it happen you've seen me do that that's
how i roll into the podcast
insert studios here says hi sheamus tim
and extras if the u.s commits civil war
ii electric boogaloo what states other
than ca do you think would balkanize
uh i don't know i i really don't know
that's an interesting salisbury probably
oh yeah i don't think it would be along
state lines
like mountain ranges would become new
borders and stuff rivers yeah there
would be like in the south there's like
people like sitting in their houses and
they have like you know an american flag
on their house and then as soon as it
breaks out they hit a button and it
flips over and it's confederate flag and
they're like i've been waiting for that
moment
all this
yeah all the state buildings just press
a button all the flags flip
it's like we were waiting
dude if you had a flag where no matter
who looked at the flag everyone would
see something different based on if you
were like tricking their mind so
everyone that sees it sees what they
want to see that'd be crazy
what would be the purpose of that that's
the
flag ian because the left sees it and
they just see racism because that's all
they want to see you know what i mean
like if i looked at that and i saw the
confederate flag because my mind was
being controlled and you look at it and
you see an amer american flag because
your mind is being controlled but i mean
that's just that's kind of how things
are now that's how things are now here's
an idea we could do we could do
polarizing lenses yeah and then we could
actually screw with people that way
where this is actually a good idea we
can set up a show at free damastan and
depending on which glasses you're given
you'll see something totally different
in the art so p like but they'll be
similar enough to where people will
describe them similarly but in different
ways to like see how they react to it
so like you put on these polarizing
glasses and depending on which way the
light's polarized you'll either see you
know joe biden or donald trump but it'll
say the worst president ever or
something would be cool to have instead
of glasses like little things you could
pull down and look through and then they
put them back up so the idea is when
people come in they get a glasses or b
glasses and then you see how they like
react to reality when they see things in
different ways
yeah that'd be cool
mr thau says you should name the new
chicks in chicken city after politicians
and world leaders then you can yell at
putin to get off hillary yeah
they're all in the back sleeping in the
incubator are they yeah watching
watching them we're gonna have to uh
take them out soon we don't know if all
of the eggs were fertilized so
at some point the eggs that aren't
hatching we just is it ethical to leave
how many like how many chicks can be in
an incubator basically is like this
they're all fine yeah it's 22
it's it holds 22 and they can be in
there for just up to three days they
don't need to eat because they have the
yolk from the egg still in them but uh
yeah you know we'll see what happens if
after a couple days some of these eggs
aren't doing anything we're just gonna
assume they're not fertilized or they
didn't make it and do you know how many
how many are there now nine how many
alive they're out on the edge yeah i
can't tell looking i really see a lot of
heads two brahma babies that they're the
ones with hairy feet so i'm really
excited for that yeah they're all lame
then and it looks like roberto junior's
a father congratulations man yeah well
but that but that means that he was
banging his dad's girl you know what i
mean i'm not gonna judge him i had to go
i didn't i had to go and give a talk uh
earlier to roberto i was like hey
roberto and come over and he actually
walked over it was funny and then i was
like so what happened was
some of the babies that were born look
like what's called a black star chicken
when you breed a rhode island red with a
barred plymouth hen
uh you'll get
a boy will be we'll have a white dot on
his head and a girl will be all black
but we ended up with penguin looking
chicks they have white chests and
they're all black and that's not either
and then i realized you know because my
brother was like i don't think those are
black stars and i was like it must be
roberto jr because he's only half rhode
island red and half some other breed i'm
not she's a easter egger of some sort
so
and we know that he's been you know
kicking it with roberto's girls so we
think that sneaking into that house
that's right that's right
i hear there are 11 hatch so far 11.
eleven that's half so what are you gonna
do with the chickens when they stop
laying because i have chickens and you
know when they get to three years old
you gotta make a decision are they just
gonna be free loaders or are you gonna
do something about it and get some fresh
ones in oh look this is the original
cast of chicken city i mean these are
celebrities
we're gonna we're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna stay there and do whatever
they want forever they got more
important jobs than just laying eggs
yeah yeah they're the stars of the show
man
but uh the roosters unfortunately have
to be retired that'll be killed but
we're setting up all boys dormitory over
at fredamastan
and it's just going to be roosters
they're useless eaters so yeah that's
true well actually i'm really interested
to see what happens when we have like 30
like full-grown adult roosters it's
gonna be interesting yeah cause i mean i
have no intention of killing or eating
them could be a party unless we have to
it'll be great to have but it's going to
be really interesting to see like this
horde of really like
i mean i'm not sure a fox will go
anywhere near him normally a fox will
kill a rooster but if you got like 30
roosters and they're all screaming
non-stop that's going to be interesting
without a weapon if you went in there
and they all attacked you i mean that
would be bad you'd get messed up so
my understanding is i've talked to a
couple breeders and i've read it online
you can house an unlimited number of
roosters with other roosters so long as
there's no hens nearby
as soon as you put a girl in the mix
they start killing each other to get
that girl so that's where i have
americana chickens they give you red
white and blue eggs although the red is
more brown and the blue is more green
but the old americana it's close enough
what colors do the easter eggers give
you green okay yeah it's it's yeah yeah
and then we we my brother bought some
fertilized eggs there's like a blue one
so i think it's a blue one we'll see
we're incubating out of these eleven
that hatched we also have another um we
had we have 56 total
that's a lot of chickens the silkies are
so funny you saw the silver yes uh i i
know i didn't see yours i know what they
look like we got silkies yeah so ostrich
something they look like llamas or
whatever yeah i was just thinking that
my neighbors have alpacas and it's the
same the ridiculous hair yeah i think
one of the tick talkers has that went to
the white house has the same hair oh my
god
but you can't put silkies and uh silky
boys in with a regular farm breed
because they'll peck the head and kill
it wow
yeah yeah you got to look up a picture
of the silkies i mean they're nothing
like it nothing i've never seen and
they're so goofy man they're they're the
silliest fluffy chicken they like to be
held yeah someone's telling me they're
they're like the friendliest chickens
they're like the panda bears of chickens
oh boy yeah yeah yeah so we're gonna so
when you mix them with regular farm
chickens you get what's called a satin
so you get very soft feathers and so
we're gonna take the once once roberto
junior are retired off to the dormitory
we're going to put the full-grown silky
rooster in to you know we got are you
going to get are you going to get any
other animals when you move to west
virginia notes
goats here in the meantime and probably
a dog so i've got a
it's a multi-step process it's really
interesting interesting thing about the
production chains i've got a um
sawmill some cutting down trees in my
property milling it into lumber using
the lumber to build a barn the barn to
house goats the goats to get milk the
milk to melt to make yogurt and so by
the end of the day i've transformed my
chainsaw into yogurt
that's awesome how long have you been
doing that uh it's taken me about a year
you know i just do it on weekends i'm
almost done with the barn so then i
should be able to get the goats this
spring
yeah someone mentioned silkies like to
cuddle that's right so um we're we
they're coop we're we're doing external
coops for the because we got extra
chickens we're gonna have a bunch
separate from chicken city next to it
but they got delayed because of you know
amazon or whatever but uh so they're all
sitting in this box with food and water
and they all just cuddle on top of each
other oh yep one of them jumped out and
tried escaping but you know it happens
all right orwell was a profit says west
virginia republican state senators just
voted down recognition of natural
immunity they need to be primaried for
this they are clearly in favor of
coveted passports and social credit
scores i agree
i can't wait till we start expanding
freedom stan um
we've got solar and being installed uh
soon the new building is being put up
it's going to help dramatically increase
security we're going to end up with two
different campuses essentially where we
do a lot of editorial stuff and
non-profit work here and then we do show
stuff and shenanigans over at freedom
stand but then we're gonna have way more
space we're gonna have it's just 50
acres it's gonna be fantastic so i'm
excited for that but that puts us in
west virginia officially where we're
gonna be way more active in local
politics and it's gonna be to the to the
point of silliness like we're talking
about you know incorporating a town we
want people to run for local office and
government and be you know if you come
out and you're working with us we want
you to be involved in politics whatever
degree you can or maybe you're someone
who comes out and gets involved and then
we start just fighting for our values
and the things we believe in and that's
what it's going to be all about plus as
we expand the company it's going more
jobs and hopefully bring more people of
like-mindedness into this area and help
revitalize the area help set the
politics on the right track i'm excited
for it
all right let's grab some more super
chats here
raymond g stanley jr says y'all get that
goat from tiny tails farms we did not
get a goat from anyone yet
but um we're not quite ready to get a
goat just yet
uh
unless jameis wants to raise some goats
wait what what did i goat farms
i have to think about it
yes is it
little tail little tail farms is that
what you're talking about you said tiny
tails yeah little tail fire you're gonna
get full size or like the miniature
nigerian probably miniature
because um i don't know if we we have
the wherewithal to take care of i think
you get like a gallon a day from the
bigger ones a gallon a day yeah i think
so yeah correct but after they after
they have babies right well of course
but the issue with the nigerians is so
you're going to get a smaller amount but
really high fat like six percent and if
you're making cheese and stuff i feel
like that's good but i feel like if
you're just drinking a glass of milk
you're gonna get pretty fat drinking six
percent milk yeah it's pretty yeah no i
think i don't think we'd be drinking the
milk we'd probably make cheese
yeah that sounds fantastic but then it's
it's only after they give birth right
yeah keep it going slightly before and
after
and so he's got to keep making more
goats yes but if you're taking the milk
from the mom what does the baby drink
uh the you know it's like with humans if
you keep breastfeeding your your body's
gonna keep making it as long as you
pumping it the but the baby doesn't
actually need it that whole time okay
maybe um we might get full size but we
were just told stay away from the boys
oh yeah stay away from the boys i would
get full size why not nobody wants boys
with anything no i
have these and it's the same thing the
boys do this is really i think i'm
becoming a feminist because
when you look at the animal kingdom boys
are just useless they don't do anything
the bees are freeloaders the boys you
know you don't get any eggs from boy
chickens you don't get any milk from boy
goats men are just terrible
yeah but it's only because humans can
protect the females right
i'll tell you what chickens uh roosters
they will sacrifice themselves to save
their girls they're heroic yeah that's
the craziest thing watching these videos
of like the rooster attacking a giant
snake and like
we had a hawk attack early on in our
other and the rooster yelled and then
ran to the door and then waited as the
other chickens all ran in and then he
ran in
watch it we throw food in and the
rooster will watch as the girls eat and
just like look around and chivalry isn't
dead yeah man the noble rooster now that
also means he takes what he wants
oh yeah
you see him at sometimes like zoos they
got to put this like diaper slash
holster on them
yeah the saddle we have some of those
otherwise that skins the feather is
going to fall off he protects the girls
but they got it they got to give him
there's a price tag
there's always a price
all right get a pair with sully says if
you get a dog for farming or livestock
protection get a maremma is it mirama
they're fantastic shepherd dogs leave
them out all year and they will be happy
aw yeah we want to get a big a big sheep
dog and there's we got 50 acres they're
gonna be running around going crazy
getting dirty you know doing dog stuff
never heard of that before yeah cool
don't be a whole lot of fun
so my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com and become a
member we're gonna have that members
only show coming up for you it'll be
published around 11 or so p.m so don't
miss it and as a member you're just
keeping all of this going so we really
do appreciate it especially with having
everything that's been happening and um
while you're waiting go over to chicken
city just search for chicken city on
youtube i don't know if we have the url
for it yeah
yet i don't know but uh go to chicken
city on youtube and you can watch live
there's babies in the incubator there's
also the chickens that are sleeping and
you can watch that and then of course at
11 pm at timcast.com we will have that
members only segment you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at tim cast luke do you want to shout
anything out
race to the bottom book check it out on
amazon right now you got social media
luke rosiak on twitter cool
freedom tunes if you guys want to check
out freedom tunes are released don't
check out freedom
you know what tim
now that you're not on there voicing
faulty anymore because he has
disappeared
well you should do it maybe he'll come
back do a cartoon of fouchy alone
he'll come back to apologize at some
point here's the pitch how about okay
hear me out all right i'm listening
vouchy alone like ian said you know and
he's crying and and and you know i'll do
the voice have some ideas i'll be like
the good old days man you know i'll come
back in we'll see here we'll laugh
you know
trouble needs to get paid bro
i mean you're telling people to get
those residuals you're telling people
not to check freedom tunes off trying to
think you're not loyal to the brand here
i don't know man
check out freedom tunes we released a
new cartoon every thursday and uh last
week i was very happy with the video we
released for thursday it was about the
uh ongoing genocide yemen and how the
united states government has aided the
saudis and committing it that's
incredible thank you hey follow me ian
crossland.net and um hit me up on social
media if you want to get in touch i'll
love you guys see you later all right i
looked up a marama and they're an
italian sheepdog that looks super
friendly and dignified and i kind of
want to get one now so thanks for that
recommendation
you guys may follow me on twitter and
mines.com at sourpatchlids we will see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out
you